[Musique]
bienvenue à s'enfuir le podcast ou est
ce qu'on parle de ce qu'on veut nous
inviter dati ci-dessus ph qu'antec moi
de me plante un petit mot pour vous
rappeler qu'on a notre page piquionne
qui est opérationnel donc si vous voulez
du contenu exclusif
tout ça est à notre page qui est dans la
description de cette vidéo là sinon
cette semaine à son filtre n'a reçu
olivier bernard aussi connu sous le nom
du pharmacien
c'est ainsi que dans le fond qui
déboulonne limites en santé en sciences
fait toutes les fausses croyances les
choses qu'on pense vraie légende urbaine
ce but fait le ménage un petit peu là
dedans c'est un coq deux fois il voulu
confronter ses plans dans ce qu'on pense
qui est vrai mais ce qui dit en tout cas
est toujours supporté par la science
donc moi j'ai appris beaucoup d'un
podcast comme à chaque pas de casse mais
qui sépare le fun vous nous écouter sur
youtube donc oubliez pas de vous abonner
à la chaîne youtube pour à chaque
semaine recevoir les notifications cas
qu'on va sortir un nouveau podcast
sinon cheikh sarr est un podcast qui
risque de faire réagir beaucoup donc
dans les commentaires n'hésitez pas à
partager votre opinion
nous on aime ça vous lire c'est sûr
qu'il faut toujours se soit fait dans le
respect on aime ce volet et interagir
avec vous donc bon vodka ce même olivier
dit qu'à l'avenir répondre aux
commentaires factice est vraiment fort
chez qui a été dit que le jus d'orange
c'est comme du coq le nul du gué bombers
caf
[Musique]
olivier merci beaucoup d'être chez nous
et merci je content d'être là yes donc
on a fait ce qu'on faisait quand est
arrivé on a fait une liste
au début quand compenser aux invités du
podcast était vraiment tête de liste
parce que la santé on s'en préoccupe
beaucoup en background et sportif les
deux puis ils ont continué à s'entraîner
dessus mais on essaie de savoir
qu'est-ce qui est ce qui est vrai qu est
ce qu il faut bien au québec et beaucoup
de monde qui le font comme toi tu y es
merci beaucoup
ouais c'est un honneur honnêtement je
suis pas content puis comme je vous ai
dit quand vous m'avez invité moi je
terminais de podcasts neuf et je te
raconterai pour participer à des
podcasts des fauches caudiès ouais c'est
cool petit avec avec ton message puis
j'imagine que souvent les entrevues avec
un car trop restreint ça fait que des
nuances qui se perdent un petit peu dans
tout le temps tout le débat puis ça doit
être plus intéressant pour toi pouvoir
exprimer à la main sur une longue
période de temps sur des sujets donné tu
es clairement moi j'ai fait des idées
comme des capsules à la télé ou à la
radio pendant peut-être deux un moment
donné c'est le pire forme aux éleveurs
parce qu'il faut que tu rentres dans 5
minutes que tu dises tout ce que tu as à
dire mais la bresse où tu réalises que
dans le fond on a oublié de dire les
trois encore des affaires qui était
temps c'est le pire forme affective pour
la santé c'était tellement complexe oui
la meilleure façon c'est juste d'en
parler ouvertement sans filtre je le
premier jt à faire un jeu de mots
honnêtement oui épisode et on n'a pas
encore goûté un bon jus d'orange et levi
james walsh d'orange s'étendit j'emboîte
pour armer mais j'aime bien ce nom je
reprends de luz et les blagues
c'est pourquoi
j'en ai entendu parler du jus d'orange
et même faiblement il ya même eu il y en
a qui ont rappelé et le jus d'orange
gates mais à quel point est-ce que ça a
été mal interprétés il un contexte ce
qui s'est passé tu étais peut-être monde
à part ouais produit des propos sur le
jus d'orange ou est ce que tu disais
c'est aussi quelqu'un qui sait que le
jus d'orange c'est comme un verre de
coca
sauf que j'imagine ça a été mal
interprétée par plusieurs personnes qui
ont enregistré leur sauter aux
conclusions que c'était pays où c'était
la même chose que le coq sur tous les
niveaux c'est ouais je sais pas si ça a
été mal interprétés je pense que je
pense la réalité c'est que ça a été plus
ça plus choqué du monde c'est ce que les
gens n'aiment pas se faire dire des
affaires comme ça parce que vous
comprendre le 4 x tout le monde en parle
de chasse par la peur et 45 minutes
il en reste à peu près comme c'est sûr
que les nuances souvent ils se perdent
puisse pas grave parce que c'est pas un
show qui forment faire la nuance est un
show qui font pour punch et puis dans ce
sens là mon entrevue qui ont passé moi
je les adore je trouve qu'ils ont fait
un montage et que rien quand je les
écoutais moi même le soir même mais j'ai
fait comme moi très cool tu sais j'étais
très contente qu'ils avaient gardé puis
tony mais mais mais c'est sûr que si le
jus d'orange de vendée ont capoté parce
que ce qu'ils ont retenu c'est boire du
jus d'orange comme boire un coca moi
quand j'en parlais dans le contexte
d'entrevue stebbins lyautey
essentiellement quand tu fais
l'extraction d'un jus d'un végétal
quelconque que ce soit fruits légumes et
c'est ce qui reste sa faim
essentiellement ses troupes et de sucre
peut-être qu'il reste un peu de
vitamines un peu de minéraux mais sans
jo vitamines minéraux cela faire la
vaisselle aller chercher dans
l'alimentation fait bref il ya pas de
différence vraiment les deux je pense
que les gens l'ont compris pour la
plupart c'est juste que y'en a qui ont
vraiment capoter positivement est
apprêté finalement ça a été bien
interpréter messages chocs et des
certitudes et des croyances on s'est
toujours fait dire qu'avant d'un verre
pour déjeuner un verre de jus d'orange
c'est la même chose cet hymne ouais moi
j'ai pas de problème est que le jus
d'orange en soit c'est au même titre que
j'ai pas de problème avec word du coq de
temps en temps je suis vraiment pas dans
la rue
qui ont alimenté le fait que j'ai pas de
problème avec ce que j'ai jamais dit aux
gens et il faut boycotter le jus
d'orange ou ceux juin de sa méga des
urgentistes sur les groupes sur facebook
et des gens qui disaient jean reuilles
le pharmacien dit qu'il fallait donner
du jus dehors il fallait donner du coca
bois le bois les niveaux un moment donné
et à quel point ce que ça peut faire
capoter le monde quand tu leur dis des
affaires comme ce que sam banal mais oui
mais complètement pis
moi j'ai adoré temps passe lentement
dans papy j'ai trouvé pis moi je t'ai
connu comme ceux comme beaucoup de gens
je mangeais nous citons connu avec le
monde en parle pour la première fois qui
est
textes et j'en parlais et tu vu entrevue
destin gaulle c'était vraiment inspirant
pigeât enfin quelqu'un qui déboulonne
les limites ce qui si tout le monde qui
m'avait une réponse positive isea oui
mussig piste -comme ou à payer dit à la
fable c'est sympa de bons simples sont
six pauvreté et jacques
premièrement c'est ok avec toi tu étais
plus un spécialiste dans ce domaine là
que tout à fait les recherches ou moins
fait que ça sonne son prenait toujours à
quel point que mon expérience de la
majeure partie des gens même on voit la
major mais d'une partie des gens ça m'a
surpris beaucoup moins aussi le jeu the
appeal affaire c'est que je vois là bas
puis là il me parle de 25 sujet
d'habitude le cheval d'un sujet tout
comme le récemment j'ai fait une bd sur
le cannabis
si j'ai fait des bd sur est maintenant
est le sucre et les choses comme ça
c'est des sujets très précis fait quand
même du monde qui veulent se chicaner
avec moi ou ce petit ciné scorait qu'on
soupçonne sur ce sujet le point le j'ai
parlé de comme à peu près 20 sujets là
dans le montage final du mont-blanc choc
quant à baptiste large dans les dents
longues qui vont être été ainsi que j'ai
choqué pour deux un mois en termes de
matons le nombre de bd que je choisis
pour deux ans le monde en l'espace de
deux semaines - bac c'est sûr que tu es
sur le coup le ça a été intense parce
que tout le monde d'allah en maudit mais
tout le monde est en maudit pour des
enfants différents points aînés qui tend
à monter à cause de ce que j'avais sur
les vaccins et donc la myopathie
d'autres le jus d'orange antioxydants
les antioxydants ci fait qu'il y avait
beaucoup de monde choqué mais pas pour
les mêmes âneries c'est là que tu vois
que on a tout quelque chose par rapport
à notre santé ou que veut veut pas leurs
noms de la mode a les jambes étant
accusé par l'achitecte qui en guillemets
disait il fait la même chose que ceux
qui critiquent utilisateurs comme ceux
mettons-y drop telle affaire c'est bon
t'as fasse pas bon mais n'explique pas
pourquoi
- pitt et j'imagine qu'ils aient
beaucoup de technicalités scientifiques
y ont été coupées au montage si tu dis
que ça détruit 45 minutes qui a failli
en reste 18 qui s'était peut-être aussi
le temps de vol en place n'ont pu faire
sur ces mêmes pentes qu'elles sont de
montage honnêtement c'est juste que tu
quand tu vois un show my mélange aux
eaux toujours aussi des références je
dois tu donnes les conclusions de
certaines recherches que tu as fait un
mois presque tous les sujets dont j'ai
parlé à tout le monde en parle par
exemple c'était soit des épisodes de ma
série télé que j'avais fait là dessus de
fait les recherches avant courant de ça
fait une immense recherche le qui prend
dix mois le type n'ont qu'à être que je
fais je fais intervenir des intervenants
la des marchés tout en fait avec des
experts qui avaient des nutritionnistes
qui était passé là dedans des chercheurs
des affaires avec moi maintenant
j'arrive à tv puis je donne voici la
conclusion de la recherche que ça a
donné
mais là c'est sûr que quelqu'un qui
qu'ils quitteraient base sur ce que je
fais ou tout ça il veut dire bah ouais
mais là il fait juste sur des
conventions qui s'en sort de son chapeau
excuses mais parce que monsieur chars
des conclusions même de mon chapeau j'ai
un ordre des professionnels le kimche
est le jour sacré dehors de mon ordre
tu peux pas dire des affaires attrait
domaine mais à gauche puis à droite le
fait que je reçois que mes enfants
soient soit ait le temps là est ce que
tu penses que en fait tout est ce que
quand tu te des propose que des propos
qui sont pas nécessairement toujours
sont pas en ligne et vers les mêmes gens
vers les mêmes croyances vas tu fais
juste déboulonner tous les mythes puis
est ce que tu penses que tu me dois
aussi des gens de ta propre formation de
ton propre milieu
ben oui c'est sûr mais c'est pas
vraiment honnêtement c'est pas une tonne
nautique en même temps la plupart des
professionnels de la santé des
scientifiques qui adore ce que je fais
pour la simple et bonne raison qu'on
pense la même affaire le monde
scientifique n'est pas controversé
benoît pas du tout outil dans le sens où
tous sont super contents d'y manger est
constamment du monde qui viennent me
voir d'un salon du livre qui me parle
dans mes conférences ont comme ces des
médecins des pharmaciens des socialistes
des biochimistes 8 rip passion comme
crime
si toutes les choses qu'on veut dire
putois ce qui est cool c'est que toi la
plateforme dont la forme c'est un pas ce
que c'est j'ai réussi à aller chercher
utile de construire des plateformes
ben oui mais c'est surtout j'étais
capable d'aller chercher le grand public
qui est la crotte de quand même tough
aller chercher pour des sujets comme la
science ou la série parce que la santé
de la science a peut être plate
longtemps la c6 s'est présenté d'une
manière aride occident avec les tripes
mais c'est ce qui en a quelques-uns qui
aiment passer au dessus et puis c'est je
sais par exemple que mes positions sur
le mien au pâtis
s'il ya des pharmaciens qui aiment sur
la myopathie l'oignon note
il ya des médecins doivent vendre
beaucoup c'est en pharmacie ouais mais
savent
oui puis non honnêtement pas tant que
non il est des produits en bois et des
produits homéopathiques et des cures
détox les producteurs de bois de la
cochonnerie d'infirmer si le pied les
pharmaciens sont au courant de tout ça
la majorité salies fait capoter ok donc
sont contents que moi j'en parle parce
qu'ils utilisent
ça va peut-être faire la demande à
changer l'offre aussi belle soit la
demande va changer ou soient menés à
quelqu'un qui va se réveiller il faut
faire comme elle sait le temps qu'on
fasse le ménage dans faut qu'on sorte la
propharmacie pas de contrôle là dessus
que ce qui me soucier établi la vaste
majorité des pharmaciens c'est dit c'est
dit salariés com - par exemple moi je
suis du remplacement
j'ai travaillé dans peut-être une
centaine de fermes à ses différentes
depuis cinq ans j'ai aucun pouvoir
décisionnel sur rien
la plupart du monde nous ont dit jobs
son pays ils sont assez petits
propriétaires
de même les propriétaires souvent n'ont
pas grand chose à dire parce que souvent
c'est les chaînes donc les lits fermés
prigioni sur uniprix et c'est heureux le
seul gagnant c'est souvent eux qui
décident parce qu'une question des deals
avec des distributeurs
soit fait une grosse game business plus
que jamais des décisions purement
clinique veut qu'on en parle un petit
peu du du milieu pharmaceutique qui tu
l'as bien dans le milieu pharmaceutique
parce que du point de vue extérieur de
keaton qui est informée mais pas autant
que j'ai l'impression que si une grosse
partie qui se joue pis au détriment de
celui qui va s'acheter les produits au
final totalement plus que tu parles des
médicaments ou tu parle en général
moi l'exemple que j'ai mon pari d'y
travailler neurochirurgie puis les
enfants il fait des opérations pour les
plaines les plans des électrodes dans le
cerveau pour le parkinson
c'est une opération qui est apparue d'un
dernier dernières décennies peut-être
puis c'est une électrode comme ça c'est
monétairement ça vaut ça vous chante
c'est autant pour les distributeurs que
pour les hôpitaux cacher le système de
santé tout liquide puis il ya quand même
une game 2 qui va fournir ses électrodes
le dit ceci ce que moi j'ai pu observer
mais j'imagine que parce que c'est mon
exemple extrêmement précis mais
j'imagine que à pleurnicher comme ça
pour tout cas je reprends ton exemple
parce qu'un exemple été car un képi
déclineront leurs différentes façons
quand tu as des compagnies qui font des
électrodes pour traiter le parkinson
sera pilote connaît pas l'efficacité je
connais pas ce produit le pantone on va
supposer que c'est un produit qui est
efficace très efficace dont good
excellent donc à la base le produit
qu'ils font est fantastique c'est un
super bon produit ça change la vie des
gens
ça change des vies ça sauve des vies je
dire c'est extraordinaire comme produit
avec ce à quoi il faut s'opposer ou être
méfiants ou 10 et 6 par rapport aux
produits en capter le produit est bon le
problème c'est comment est ce que les
compagnies commercialisent bah
évidemment ils veulent faire de la
promotion là-dessus faits qui font du
marketing comment tu fais du marketing
de différentes façons en ayant en
faisant de la dea des campagnes
publicitaires en r d représentant qui
vont aller voir les médecins qui vont
essayer de vendre leur bébé et cetera on
sait pertinemment qu'un médecin qui se
fait visiter par des représentants
pharmaceutiques est influencée évidence
le vul s'était montrée ici démontré dans
de la lutte dans la littérature
scientifique c'est très démontré un
médecin qui se fait visiter par un
représentant pharmaceutique peu importe
même s'il représentait rendant le bureau
puis qui dit comment ça a été tu as fait
une semaine qui parle juste de leur fin
de semaine ou du golfe là le truc même
en fait c'est oui c'est sûr ça fait
partie de la game puis après ça j'ai
travaillé dans l'industrie
pharmaceutique pendant six ans dans le
passé
non je la connais la game parfaitement
notre break et donc font du marketing
ils font de la vente qui font de la
vente sous pression
on peut remonter un peu plus loin il
accompagna le fait des études pour
prouver que ces électrodes sont
efficaces est ce que c'est et dessus de
l'oeil ont été bien construite dès fois
l'état les compagnies ont tendance à
comme pousse t un peu les études pour
s'assurer qu'ils vont donner à peu près
le résultat qui veulent veut pas dire
que les deux dépôts bonne soit pas dire
que l'électro dépôt bonne mais ça veut
dire que haas et assuré qu'elle allait
avoir des résultats qui sont vraiment
très haute
ils ont peut-être choisi ils ont été
choisis les comparateurs pour que ça les
arrange
peut-être qu'ils ont eu à mener une
étude qui a pas bien fonctionné oups ils
l'ont pas publier celle là qui ont je
suis oubliez moi elle est oubliée deux
côtés ont oublié entre guillemets du
texas et des stratégies que les
compagnies vont utiliser pour essayer de
pousser leurs produits le plus possible
est ce que ça veut dire que le produit
par don non ça veut dire que la façon de
s'y prendre
est mauvaise et c'est ça il faut qu'on
lutte contre nettement ce genre de
pratique le ouais ça mettons auf
au final est ce qu'il ya une espèce de
surenchère de ses produits le par les
compagnies dans le sens
ben admettons que tu réussis à
justement prendre certaines études
ciblées tt résultats positifs dissimulé
résultats négatifs faire valoir une plus
value à ton produit à toi j'imagine que
tu rajoute aussi une valeur monétaire
ben en fait tant en plus sur ses seins
c'est ça le point et le point c'est que
c'était capable de démontrer par toutes
sortes de stratégies de marketing que
nos produits c'est le meilleur je te
convaincre les médecins que ton pote sur
mobiles vont utiliser plus qu'il avait
titré une tonne de cash sur ses solides
et avec l'âge en soit c'est pas un
problème dans le sens où les gens aiment
peau sur l'idée qu'un médicament aucun
produit médical pharmaceutique que ça
soit un bien qu'on veut c'est bizarre
oui puis non c'est à dire que si on veut
que si on veut créer de l'innovation
il faut qu'il y ait de la business line
productions ben oui ittifaq je faisais
ça c'est inévitable les gens sont pas
confortables avec cette idée là mais
c'est juste une réalité un peu le
problème c'est les pratiques c'est que
les pratiques dans le milieu
pharmaceutique médical agroalimentaire
etc
ça manque de transparence l'éthique la
bassée c'est discutable c'est douteux
factice ce il faut qu'on change des
choses à ce niveau là le gouvernement
met pas ses culottes suivant la
réglementation à ce niveau un manque
beaucoup de pas assez strictes d'accès
s'éveiller là le problème finalement et
plusieurs problèmes était l'exemple du
du gaz aux etats unis c'est quoi son nom
c'était l'été la médicamentation pour le
site de crédit bureau qu'est ce qui
s'est passé dans ce cas là parce que lui
c'était le c'est un sujet que je sais
que je connais énormément mais lui dans
le fond il y avait sur et acheter les
droits d'un médicament que les gens qui
sont atteints de ces deux prix augmenter
de mille pour cent de ce pays est ce
parce qu'il y avait pas d'autres
compétitions
exact mais en fait il ya quelque chose
d'important mentionné je comprends ta
question surenchère c'est que aux états
unis et au canada c'est très différent
commence quand le prix des médicaments
aux etats unis c'est là
la loi de l'offre et de la demande donc
autrement dit tu peux y mettre le prix
du voeu qui finalement le prix va
s'ajuster en fonction de la compétition
s'était pas de compétition mais
théoriquement tu peux mettre ton prix ou
de briques au canada cependant même sa
marque et au canada on est dedans on
fait partie des sept grands pays
industrialisés qui finalement vont
prendre une décision ensemble sur ce
commerce qui vont mettre le prix des
médicaments
donc il ya un organisme qui parlera
gouvernementale qui va établir d un
intervalle j'entends me dise comment tu
peux le vendre en tant pis tant qu' donc
le sait police les politiques décident à
combien ils vont au canada on est
chanceux à ce niveau là on est chanceux
par contre le problème qu'on est au
canada c'est le problème des médicaments
génériques ou si vous êtes un peu
familier que le concept médicaments
génériques sont des médicaments qui sont
des copies de médicaments originaux sont
dans dans les pharmacies mais qui sont
là la marque maison
oui piper ressources sur les tablettes
mais nous au laboratoire quand tu serais
comme pharmacien
la majorité des médicaments qu'on parle
silico pile c'est pas du médicament
toffifee agro l'abrutissement venons
tout le monde connaît deux tibias groupe
du viagra générique donc une compagnie
qui fait une copie du viagra
sommes-nous ses médicaments le chez nous
ici sont très très cher parce que
justement il bénéficie du fait que le
marché contrôlé petit lait opl
ils peuvent vendre leurs médicaments
copier à des prix que sont exorbitants
alors que finalement c'est pas
nécessairement ça ça devrait être
beaucoup plus bas mais quelque chose d
avantages des inconvénients notre
situation mais au final ces médicaments
génériques reviennent quand même moins
cher au consommateur que les médicaments
de tout à fait puis - d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça que la balle à l'apport des
pharmaciens formation comment générer
quoi on recommande les génériques basket
c1 c'est moins cher pour l'état c'est
moins cher pour la personne c'est moins
cher pour les assurances les pharmaciens
en plus des pharmacies font une marge de
profit plus élevé dessus c'est vraiment
un avantage de plus que son peu tapé la
recherche ce qui est un peu frustré mais
en même temps on en a besoin des copies
de ces masques et m'emmener c'est une
compagnie alain un brevet est un produit
allemand pendant tant d'années précise
comme ok le fait on cache supposément
bain car on passe à autre chose ça c'est
encore le site tout à fait qu'un certain
nombre d'années qu'il compagnie peut
garder l'exclusivité de commandes année
en fait ces 20 mai 20 ans
l'embêtant c'est 20 à partir du moment
où toutes faites la demande de brevet
mais le moment où tu fais ta demande de
brevet il sait que le ltte pas encore
téléphones portables en général et en
éprouvette le site est en train de faire
des expériences avec une pipe et tu mets
des petites gouttes sur des cellules
le twin demandes de brevets parce que tu
penses que ta molécules alain potentiel
mais les traces il est quinze ans de
recherche affaires extérieures bon et
c'est sa fille qui va peut-être rester
5,8 en deux sur le marché pour pouvoir
rattraper facebook les médicaments son
char domaine c'est que les compagnies
veulent rattraper peut-être d'évoquer un
an de recherche en l'espace de cinq ans
c'est une des raisons pourquoi ce choix
de mon combat c'est intéressant vraiment
j'avais quatre cartes est allé à tout le
monde en parle justement pour rebondir
encore sur les médicaments ou les
médicaments les médicaments en pharmacie
et l'homéopathie aussi j'aimais quand tu
disais je pense que c'est ce qui était à
côté de toi moko à quelqu'un qui dit
ouais mais si c'est l'effet placebo
s'écoule par hape métier l'effet placebo
s'écoule sans que personne ne fasse de
l'argent sur le dos de quelqu'un qui
croit à l'essai ces gens entre eux c'est
vrai que si c'est moi qui étais d'accord
mais c'est vrai parce que tu es mettons
et tu prends le l'ex traque de pissenlit
là que se situe ma blonde à laver une
[ __ ] des extraits de senlis
la production des pilules d'extraits de
pissenlit je pensais qu'il avait inventé
ce nom mais c'est comme ça réduit
l'inflammation nous deux on vient d'un
milieu scientifique nos pères 6,6 des
médecins etc
quand même deux personnes assez
cartésienne pis moi ça j'ai jamais cru à
ce jamais sauf que quand je confronté à
quelqu'un qui croie je me questionne
garmin jadis que salade et bien fait
c'est sur la santé ce que ça peut
améliorer crois que ce soit un bon
esprit critique c'est pas de tout
accepter ou tunis de dante et deux
hectares et une nouvelle affaire si des
fois l'examen critique dessus ça passe
par l'examen
ça ne passe pas surgis de suite c'est
pas mieux non plus de quoi en fait le
squale affaire c'est que dans le domaine
de la santé le hockey on fonctionne avec
les ans fonctionne avec la médecine
basée sur les données probantes dans
diverses avant de faire des informations
on peut les tester on peut les tester
dans des essais cliniques
on peut faire des vérifications et puis
après son plein gré avec certains de
répondre ok c'est essentiellement la
santé semaine ça marche
ok donc moi le skate comme dit le jus de
pissenlit ou juste pour l'extrait de
puissance en capsules
ça fait quoi déjà khady sarr est usée
elle est flamand si ça réduit
l'inflammation parfait donc s'ils font
une affirmation comme celle-là - jeu
matin moi j'ai aucun problème avec ça je
suis 100% ouvert à ça mais ce que je
m'attends d'eux c'est qu'ils puissent le
démontrer que ça va pas être
certainement moins le consommateur qui
va être et qui va essayer de le
démontrer à la place de la compagnie
qu'il vint la compagnie a la
responsabilité de montrer que ce cas la
firme est vrai ok donc il faut qu'un
fournissent des études à l'appui
c'est aussi simple que ça moi là c'est
juste que les gens les pressions sur la
gauche contre les produits naturels nous
avons quand même s'imposer pour espérer
par tout les ans le plein de produits
naturels que je recommande
mais c'est qu'une compagnie fait une
information holla holla de voix rauque
et de le fardeau de la preuve doit
démontrer que son produit ont été
démontrées efficace dans des études
fiables et malheureusement dans la
quasi-totalité des cols et produits
naturels ne sont pas capables de faire
cette démonstration l'heure donc en fait
ils sont en train de mentir
ils sont en train de dire des choses
qu'ils n'ont pas vérifié tecmo c'est ça
le problème que je mets ces quelques
russes faire telle affaire c'est que on
ne peut choix en tant que citoyen
consommateur de faire confiance
aux sommités ou un consensus mais ouais
si je veux moi me faire ma propre idée
et émettons je prends un exemple moi
j'étais un gros consommateur de lait
depuis que je te petit jean bouin
énormément t il eu quand j'ai grandi
tout est brûlé le steak sommes même
qu'ils étaient bons pour théo
il se pilote depuis une couple d'années
on entend de plus en plus que et
peut-être des enfants qui y sont
serait pas bon pour la santé dans les
cancers de la prostate peut-être
d'autres autre affaire mais le moi si je
veux si je vais checker ben ouais je
veux ou tu départ de donner au dessus
parce que tu es les étudiants voient
passer mettons des études dans les
médias qui cite une étude sur les
articles les articles mais qu'il est
titré ce patron par finalement vraiment
sur l'étude c'est ça ça veut dire
mettons justement tu es le bleu mais que
le cancer mais tu te rends compte que
les tunisiens en laboratoire des
cellules ou des souris tu t'es tu le
sais mais bref il ya dessus à ce
contrôle dessus un moyen pour google
grandeur est ce que c'est suffisant
normaux le survol une méta analyse des
dix mille études de petit mil 2010 sur
un sujet pour me faire mon deuil et de
ses moyens qui tient un moyen seul à la
question que je me pose la question je
me fais poser plus souvent cités comme -
le comme consommateur comme un choix
pour me faire une idée qui est fiable
sur quoi que ce soit at elle dit est
elle produit et que si greg tels
médicaments peu importe qui la réalité
c'est que c'est pas plus facile pour les
scientifiques de se faire une tête sur
ces sujets lol comme moi par exemple je
donne je donne un exemple les quais toi
rien de parler d'être pour ma saison 2
mais série télé j'ai fait un épisode sur
le vif et je me suis moi même au début
raconter une histoire dans ma tête je me
suis dit que j'allais faire une revue de
littérature sur les laits moi même parce
que normalement la plupart des sujets
c'est moi qui fais ma propre recherche
s'est vu que c'est un peu ma spécialité
moi d'analyser de manière critique la
littérature scientifique
quand j'arrive à la littérature devant
les loups je ne suis pas capable c'est
impossible impossible à battre audio
métro détient une que trop d'études ça
va dans toutes les directions
je suis pas dans mon champ d'expertisé
avec gégé abandonné j'ai dit je ne peux
pas faire ce donc à ce moment là j'ai
fait intervenir des experts dans mon
épisode qui eux se sont concentrés sur
des aspects très spécifique rouler avec
le huit du lot est obligé de te fier sur
certaines personnes c'est qu'ils vont
avoir décortiqué la littérature pour
certains aspects c'est par exemple c'est
quoi le risque de cancer associé chose
c'est quoi la valeur nutritive du lait à
etc mais pour beaucoup de qu'on peut
pour ces pauvres faibles pour répondre à
ta question là
la plupart du temps c'est presque
impossible de faire ce travail là
moi quand je réaffirme ainsi une des
questions je me fais poser plus souvent
aussi c'est quelqu'un qui arrive aux
contres woippy qui disait j'ai pris ce
produit le sait et tablettes le site
écrit aux sites et aux mauves power 3 on
me dit quelque chose au regard diocèse
d'ingrédients dames c'est comme seul
est ce que ça marche cela c'est à peu
près une des questions les plus
compliqués que peut poser information et
formation parce que cela ça va me
demander des recherches de probablement
plusieurs heures voire plusieurs jours
pour pouvoir répondre à cette question
le tacon bras dessus que c'est c'est
très très difficile de faire sauter une
femme une vraie analyse la littérature
là c'est vraiment complexe il faut que
tu fasses ta propre recherche faut que
tu a comparé à la recherche d'autres
personnes qui ont fait la même recherche
que toi
ce travail de thèse cc c'est très
compliqué puis même à la fin tu est
obligé d'avoir une certaine humilité où
tu dis garde j'en ai peut être échappé
des bottes l'homme et voici ce qui
semble se distinguer grippe toutes les
meilleures bêtes là c'est ce qu'on
appelle les revues systématiques des
revues systématiques c'est dans le fond
des groupes qui sont complètement
indépendants de tout le monde loin
devant l'industrie du x y z puis vont
faire ils vont faire une analyse de
toute la littérature qui vont aussi
analyser la qualité des études passent
des études longues de crapules qui se
publie la majorité des autres qu'ils
publient c'est n'importe quoi c'est des
études pour il que tu peux rien rien moi
je suis là d'un jaune est longue
c'est ça le problème fait qu ils vont
faire dire ils vont faire maintenant des
analyses de toute la littérature sur un
sujet ils vont en tirer de grandes
conclusions entre des groupes comme
cochrane par exemple si les gens veulent
aller là dessus continent point org
ils font ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
fantastique cochrane méthode livre tu
vas pouvoir trouver des réponses à
certaines questions pompe que des fois
il ya des moyens de faire ça comme ça
mais c'est ça c'est vraiment difficile
parce que tu es je prends l'exemple du
litige quand j'écoute est un épisode le
j'avais samoa
pour rassurer dans un sens strict il n'y
avait pas nécessairement de raisons
nutritionnelle de consommer de l'aimer
mais que aussi t'es pas essentiel qu'on
pouvait le penser 06 par autre chose
totalement cessé le consensus
sauf qu'elle est en train de le lay
j'avoue que c'est notre moi je moi j'ai
grandi en me faisant dire que voilà
fallait absolument consommé du lait et
des produits laitiers pour mille en
bonne santé le souci n'est pas pourquoi
le jeudi c'est l'industrie laitière qui
nous a mis ça dans ta gueule on n'a
aucunement besoin de lait pour être en
santé l'âge ou les laisse une bonne
source de protéines est une bonne source
de calcium ton calcium des cas pas aller
chercher ailleurs facilement python fait
qu'ils aient besoin du les laissez pas
mauvais dans consommer non plus le temps
train de lire les ordonnances des années
votre bouquin qui le lui dit qu arrêter
d'en consommer kir et des liens que les
notes restant très classique
c'est vrai que j'ai pas du tout les
chapitres du livre d'alain dessus je le
lis comme je le lis ils sûrement bien
sûr matampi je lis comme dans le
désordre un peu de temps en temps je
mens soir puis julie un chapitre mais
c'est ce qui est embêtant dis c'est que
oui c'est sûr que tu peux regarder puis
il ya une augmentation du risque de
cancer de la prostate mais l'autre
comment est-ce que tu prennes décision
clinique en lien avec ce problème à ckoi
l augmentation de risque
les walis remettons aux ya une
augmentation de 20% au shit c'est
beaucoup moins même temps c'est quoi ton
crise de base à 6 0 point 1 1% et 0
point 1 % augmenté de 20%
ça fait 0 point 3 0 points 12 ce serait
faire une grosse augmentation par contre
si dans ta famille ou et un historique
de cancer de la prostate le sens amène
toute notre tout est là dessus c'est
pour ça prend des décisions
individuelles sur des sur des
affleurements c'est juste un défi de
énorme énorme énorme énorme définitive
c'est que j'ai compris justement les ans
dans son livre que souvent voici comme
sparrow c'est une augmentation de 15%
20%
mais c'est comprendre qu'une
augmentation 20 % c'est pas vingt fois
plus le c1 une virgule deux fois plus le
titre hypo bonne grosse augmentation 6
et mettant quelque chose qui touche une
personne sur mille tavaux touché une
points deux personnes sûr mais aussi ses
problèmes en le concept qui est le plus
d'efforts mais dans les médias et les
raisons les médias se dire on vient de
découvrir que telle chose augmente de 3
fois le risque de cancer ou à l inverse
que quelque chose est liée à trois fois
moins d'alzheimer la filature garde les
scripts donne c'est comme c'est juste
une façon de présenter les chiffres cpie
quand tu regarde vraiment ok mais les
trois fois plus trois fois moins c'est
par rapport à ce que les chiffres de
base
tu te rends compte que d'enfance qui
micro différence le fait que ces
stratégies malhonnêtes qui comprendrait
sans pourtant deux fois plus que les
statistiques là c'est super dur à
comprendre
laval elle était la majorité des gens du
public ne maîtrise pas bien
les chiffres les statistiques et la
majorité des professions de la santé ne
maîtrise pas bien les statistiques si
oui exact l'on va pas se leurrer le jeu
dire les pharmaciens les médecins et
nutritionnistes pour toutes des
expériences des stats le fait que
eux-mêmes des fois pas pu se faire un
petit peu à voir parce que juste pas
qu'alain soir pascal s en est un qui est
très très fort là dessus je pense que
dans ce cas-ci ce problème décision qui
prend personnellement c'est aller plus
loin et dire en fait allé comme on est
des amis on se connaît super à bien des
choses qu'on fait lui puis moi qui y
sont pas rationnels totalement le pion
aux scénaristes par rapport à son lycée
moi je prends comme exemple au début
juillet de lui parce qu'il prenait 12
ans inc quand il ya de la rue m pour
prévenir le rhume de juillet les huit
halls table moi je réalisais to the west
of ou finalement la star j'emprunte
cessez jamais blanc ou noir
mais souvent on peut quand même tiré des
conclusions en disant par exemple les
gardiens des bonnes chances que ça
marche pas ou que des paupières chances
que ça marche on est capable du résultat
entre heineken mois commence à boire du
café à cause de l'huile
non mais pourquoi parce que j'en ai
jamais vu dans ma vie puis j'ai toujours
été méfiant je me suis dit
ça reste quelque chose une drogue très
doucement j'ai pas le goût d'être
dépendant à rien à envie parce que
jamais vraiment consommé à part dans des
situations extraordinaires des drogues
et de l'alcool
imprimer encore le pot de façon et moi
c'est assez du gvl quotidienne avec le
jeu si ça prend ça chaque jour c'est
comme un stimulant chaque jour pas
manipuler lui c'est quoi son point c'est
que la caf une c'est bon quoi c'est que
la caféine c'est bon je vais l'appeler
non c'est non mais j'y consommation
moyenne de 3 5 tonnes sur ce beaucoup
moins mais s'est dit que paul ii fait
négatifs que malgré des effets positifs
ont tout à fait pire note des effets
positifs comme par exemple pour pour
pour les gens qui s'en prennent la
caféine c'est un super bon pour
augmenter la performance très très
efficace et reprenait d'ailleurs moi
j'en prenais j'en prenais beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup augmenté le pain café
en pilules de caféine puis tu es tu sais
rien
bref moi écoute moi c'est une triste que
je t'avais voire plus en rétrospective
maintenant que je me suis intéressé plus
à la nutrition par mon passage
organismes on en reparlera plus tard
mais je me suis intéressé à question
davantage ses piges pour réaliser que ce
que je m'étais fait dire avance ne paie
pas un serment la bonne affaire pour
moitié puis mais ce qui m avait dit sa
nutritionniste d'assermenter
d'entraînement jusqu'à 400 mg de caféine
avant les entraînements puisque et
quatre pilules de 100 grammes c'est ce
qui est à peu près huit cafés les
mettons le puits
c'est maintenant une zone des gt gt gt
le meilleur physiquement mais classé
physique était étaient bien porteurs qui
pompait trop non je n'ai pas de carte
progrès tome est ce que ça faisait c'est
que ça dérègle est complètement mon
cycle de sommeil dans ça me choque et
rob complètement je peux faire deux
sièges avec les deux yeux grands ouverts
de même en compétition c'est encore pire
je pensais avant dé finale i tunes anges
à 6h01 le soir en finale tu prends
quatre pilotes qui finalement est final
dors pas de la nuit mais c'était pas
mieux le lendemain matin
ouais ouais c'est ça c'est que tu peux
pas avoir un peu par une intervention
pour la santé qui ajuste des bénéfices
de ces jo zosso tout d'abord des
désavantages avec la caféine ça peut
augmenter la performance sportive c'est
bien démontré on le sait fait dans ce
sens là c'est intéressant si après ça
ben oui ça peut nuire au sommeil
il ya des gens que ça va augmenter leur
pression artérielle et ses rôties effet
qu il ya aussi des joueurs backs est-ce
que la caféine c'est bon ou pas bon
6 c'est relativement c'est comme si moi
je rencontre des membres qui me disent
hey
- je boite 12 cafés par jour penses tu
que tu as un problème
oui je comprends mais pourquoi tu me
poses la question tient bien d'autres si
moi je veux pas que chirac affirme parce
que j'ai pas d'être dépendance josé
regard oui là sa cause d'une légère
dépendance lac et financé le cachera pas
sa légende et mornas puis quand tu
arrêtes d'empreintes sevrage en mangeant
moi je bois un café par jour
et puis si jamais su ce qu'était une
journée gégé le malouin beaucoup là dans
le sens que si je m'en passerais qui à
fait raison sur la forme aussi c'est au
goût c'est probable l'émeute a le goût
fait que mieux ne pas commencer dans le
fond dans un contexte performance
sportive je comprends bien port de souda
en vie en général je disais c'est quoi
le bienfait de prendre du café mais il y
en a que ça les rêver il y en a que ça
les aide à se concentrer le matin à
justin fonction poe matinale depuis dix
mois le mon café les images à fonctions
un peu plus le matin car il y en a pas
de problème le sait juste que bois
impôts saint-claude séisme qui répartit
le post toute la journée parce que comme
tu dis il boit du café ou suppose comme
quand il vraiment un mauvais plein
tu vas le café aussi c'est un peu
l'effet cigarettes le titre monde qui a
même pas le goût la cigarette mais que j
aime aller prendre l'habitude de sortir
dehors pour fumer une cigarette dehors
dit c'est le café ça peut être aussi le
tir mais j'aime / me lever le matin puis
faire mon coeur est ici comme une
routine que j'aime train dé tant pis je
continue à faire
on est tellement accroché à des enfants
de même c'est vrai les camps mais c'est
drôle parce qu'il y avait quand même je
pouvais y en a pas qui me fait rire
beaucoup ma blonde puis - là c'est genre
le mettons le monde qui valait qui font
des dépenses de rbm bil'in pilet il met
une photo de deux personnes en train de
boire prendre leur café sur le balcon
comme un moment il ya quelque chose de
très social de très constant ciel voir
un espresso sur une terrasse à paris ou
extérieur la cigarette c'est la même
chose si ça contribue au phénomène de
dépendance c'est parce que la dépendance
physique
jallet dépendance psychologique la
dépendance puisque le jeu que c'est
juste l'habitude si tu bois ton café
avec du monde socialement people juste
l'habitude mais six mois plus tard à
défaire ce n'est pas pour les gens que
des gens que pour eux c'est facile
d'accès plus difficile la cigarette
c'est la même chose y en a qui copient y
en a qui arrêtent jour la mère fume un
mois son corps est qu'avec ça mais ce
qu'ils trouvent tough c'est que la pause
cigarette ou qui jasaient que leurs amis
leurs collègues c'est ce qui leur manque
d'un amoureux ça peut être sur la
difficulté c'est vraiment variable oui
c'est sûr curieux parce que ya dix ans
les épisodes de la série qui est sur les
primes alimentaires
oui à part les cafés tout prenait sur
autre chose que ce que j'ai une certaine
pas
ou est ce que j'avais un espèce de mx2
tn avec de la caféine
je connais pas de café à ce moment là
c'était c'est ce qu'ils appelaient des
fabuleux ça mettait ça faisait que je
suis en innocent la tige ce je le voyais
physiquement différent ce jeu suez
résultat pire ou là j'avais les postes
132 relaxe plus j'étais trempé comme
s'ils venaient là dedans douchy ouais
ressources avaient servi à grand chose à
part me faire perdre de l'eau sinon
après ce créatif
j'ai pris la créatine
est ce que j'ai vu des effets concrets
non mais disent c'est comme aller
maximiser les enfants et j'ai pas bon et
j'en prenais pas ce qu'on me disait que
c'était bon pied après cela dépend de
louis xi dans le domaine du support
c'est ce qui est embêtant c'est que les
athlètes c'est les principales victimes
de tout le marketing autour des sublimes
table allemand qui moi je prends un
athlète le mais du point de vue de notre
lettre comprend tout à fait que tu dis
garni c'est quelque chose qui peut
améliorer de 5% tandis que ça
la créatine sommes en exemple la
chrétienne on parle des augmentations de
performance de 3 5% à 6 seulement 18 c
puis je me dis à huit c'est pas beaucoup
mais donc c'est beaucoup mais quand même
je donne tellement tout ma vie bourse
c'est ça que 8 % c'est toujours moins 8
% et +3 5% quand ça se calcule en
centièmes de secondes ça fait différent
oui pis ça je le comprends puis à la
limite ce pas un problème en notant que
c'est sécuritaire
les suppléments de créatures dont elle
la sicile sud et 6.1 supplément qui
était spa etc etc d'autres affaires puis
tout s'est pas nécessairement dangereux
de prendre la créatine fait que moi j'ai
pas compris ce qu'un athlète fait ça
mais monsieur madame tout le monde voit
le jeu et nous on va les pharmacies du
supplément de créatine ce que je trouve
complètement aberrant j'entends le toit
le dougie le moyen je veux commencer à
mantes je commence à m'entraîner au jam
je me souviens d'entraînement chez
énergie cardio bleus je pensais commence
à prendre des suppléments pour mes deux
comme nom jeu n'ont pas entraîné comme
ce monde qui comme on verra le si un
jour le tu peux faire un podium on sent
pas l'heureux était de haut niveau c'est
une fraction 1% le plus commun leurs
chèques de créatine on est confiné
ajouté
les gays étaient pas en shape le sais je
le voyais les tiges de ligue 1 n'était
pas celle ci avait du travail à faire un
million de travail à faire aller
chercher 5% le sillon des non pas de
sion des 75% aller chercher à voir que
les chercher sa petite affaire facile
c'est moi j'ai fait une entrevue avec
une nutritionniste qui est là l'entrain
des athlètes olympiques le genre
entraîne des athlètes de judo au look
sont des machines de guerre dont
j'entends puis a dit souvent c'est ce
qui les amène à moins qu'ils viennent me
voir parce qu'ils veulent optimiser
leurs suppléments et - l'optimisme -
dans le sens que je m'imagine que chez
un nutritionniste m'a dit finalement ce
que j'obtiens cela c'est leur
alimentation bien sûr c'est difficile
souvent leur alimentation et pologne
et ce jeu le petit mise puis je les
amène à délaisser certains suppléments
dont ils ont pas besoin et s'ils veulent
qu'on soit allé prendre les prendrons
mais souvent c'est juste la nutrition
les gens qui souvent ne réalisent pas à
quel point la nutrition c'est la base de
berlin en ville bien plus que les
produits naturels les suppléments et
même dans certains cas certains risques
à man ouais présent c'est la nutrition
justement parlons-en parce que beaucoup
de gens peuvent se sentir perdus par
rapport à ça toutes les croyances qu'on
attire moins pendant un but je mangeais
enregistré quasiment tout les jours
parce que justement je m'entraînais
puisque je croyais c'était que c'était
la meilleure chose que je pourrais
prendre c'est pour mon apport en
protéines pour toute l'équipe le
montrant que ce moment où tu as montré
des avants maintenant puis plus de la
même façon ouais mais malgré tout j'en
mange pas j'en ai juste pas besoin
d'outils puis moi dans la taille de
terrassa affaire qui était vraiment
optimales j'imagine qu'il ya tellement
de
tellement d'idéologies différentes c'est
difficile de savoir comment qu'on se
retrouve l'habitude ce qu'est ce qui
fait en fait que en santé puis parce que
même en nutrition j'ai l'impression que
c'est tellement difficile de savoir où
il va là dedans c'est le pays et la
serbie la santé à la base c'est toujours
le duff de se faire une idée la
nutrition le sait le sous segment de la
santé plus que le plus de pseudo science
si on parle d'autres domaines la science
po d'astrophysique léger mais quelqu'un
qui dit je crois pas gâté reid la
gravité jamais rien eu
c'est moi il m semble qu'hier
l'existence des trous noirs qui démente
qui doute
mais voici le soient c'est la phase
étude qui s'intéresse au trône world
envie ou le trou noir laqué laquelle
impact sur notre vie à tous puis -
musiciens c'est à chaque jour 3 c'est
tout le monde c'est 100 % de la
population fait que tout le monde a
l'impression que son mot à dire sur la
nutrition parce que ça nous rejoint dans
notre vie on a tout d expérience très
personnelle des anecdotes des choses au
crou à auxquelles on croit très
fermement ce que tout le monde à un
aliment que si on est comme ça je peux
pas en manger
neil chose ça me fait à la sphère que
cette erreur avec tout le monde devient
un peu un expert la nutrition pour soi
même ce qui est correct
j'ai toujours su par l'osce a dit
embêtant c'est que souvent les gens ont
tendance à généraliser
donc tu vas avoir des gens qui vont se
faire comprendre des choses de appeal et
ils vont comme zéro mais voilà c'est ça
c'est 100 % de la population qui doit
faire ce mois j'ai coupé le gluten pour
tout le monde coupe le gluten c'est
taxer beaucoup sur le fait que tout le
monde se sent tout le monde s'inquiète
un mot à dire sur la nutrition plus que
sur les trous droit en attendant son
m'excuse ce qui se passe ce qui fait que
c'est difficile aussi parce que tu es
clairement on remarquer différentes
personnes réagissent différemment des
aliments se regarde juste mettant des
gens qui sont situés devant le rejet
commun qui sont intolérants traîneau à
faire clairement sur des aliments pour
certaines personnes causes différentes
choses
mais est-ce que plus largement ça peut
être différente si y est telle qu elle
dit y est et pour une personne pourrait
vraiment pas fonctionné pour une
personne puisse fonctionner ben oui
c'est sûr on est définitivement oui
c'est la fête et où la ati la vérité
absolue en fond et il y en a pas
finalement
en fait le ça dépend c'est à dire que
d'une chose ou encore le poste était
super content que cette affaire-là parce
que je suis allé j'ai l'impression que
quand on fait des études cliniques ayant
l'impression que l'étude clinique doit
leur donner une réponse pour eux
spécifiquement disponble ça marche la
science le une étude clinique le
principal ou peu importe une étude que
tu fais sur une diète quelconque
maintenant lorsque trois ans qui va
prendre un méchant gros groupe de
personnes qui tue vous regardez qu'est
ce qu'ils mangent du tout et il tirait
des conclusions parce que ça permettrait
à se tirer de grandes conclusions pour
l'ensemble la population autrement dit
la majorité des gens ok mais à partir du
moment où tu as dû te trouver certaines
affaires exemple on va sûrement parlé
tantôt lomé
on le sait aujourd'hui l'une des rares
choses qu'on sait avec certitude dans la
main de l'alimentation c'est que manger
le plus de végétaux possible c'est pas
mal la meilleure enquête plus fermes ta
santé aux personnes qui en doutent de ce
que ça c'est la grande conclusion pour
tout le monde l'appréciait tu vas voir
des gens que zoo qui vont ils vont se
mettre sur une diète végétarienne qui
vont ça va être horrible je capable a
tôt fait pas que tout à un niveau de
notre système isation occupera les
études d après sa belle aux 8,6 pour
chaque personne ya des petites
variabilité interindividuelle mais les
grandes conclusions il reste quand même
d'allied pour peut-être comme tic 95% de
la population
triki quand même majeurs mais ça
n'empêche pas que tout peut être un
excellent agent qui nous écrivent ces
qui veulent devenir vegan mais qu' ils
sont allergiques à tous qu'ils essayent
tout ce qui est légumineuses puis après
ça c'est comme qu'est ce que je fais en
crise parce que je sais pas comment tu
peux
ça va être dur ça c'est peut-être
faisable mais ça va être difficile puis
ça risque d'être une alimentation qui va
être assez plate mais oui c'est ce qui
risque d'être pas très nutritive nom
prince fait que un moment donné il faut
arrêter de penser qu'il ya une diète qui
fonctionne pour tout le monde puis c'est
seul problème en ce moment c'est qu'un
ndiaye qui dit en mode c'est bon pour
tout le monde et à utiliser les gens qui
font la promotion d'autres il ya une
couple d'années c'était le paléo
populaire dit qu'ils étaient en bonne
santé
l'espérance de vie il n'y avait pas pire
espérance de vie sans voix et sérieux il
vivait quand même beaucoup plus vieux
qu'on pense mais il y avait toutes les
maladies qui existent aujourd'hui les
artères bouchées par le cholestérol le
cas ça existait à l'époque des zones qui
avaient complètement le monde mourait
mais on se disait justice à lui
commander sa belle-mère le cancer de
tout le corps au complet c'est que soit
le savez pas où vous encore vivait pas à
city mais on pense que vous devez vivre
facilement dans la cinquantaine des
choses comme ça mais c'est les maladies
qu'on vaut aujourd'hui beaucoup ce n'est
maladie qui se développe justement
partir de 5 ans comme la plupart des
cancers et des maladies jusqu'à 10 h
exactement ces faits qu'il a dit paléo
pillowman listel et paléo pour tout le
monde surtout les athlètes apprécié a eu
le centre lui tn le sans gluten il ya eu
une passe un moment donné où il y avait
des études et des sondages qui disait
qu' il y avait
jean 30% de la population un moment
donné qui se déclarerait qu'en c'est
intolérable de lutter s'est appuyé sur
1%
c'est en fait c'est un pur sans que la
maladie coeliaque qui peut vraiment pas
en consommer puis après ça il y en a
peut-être des gens intolérants au gluten
saas permet à 30% de la population se
désole le fait qu'il représente
cela-dit apple qui tôt ou d'un tueur à
la dialyse et aux jeunes qui n'avaient
pas pu l'air puis encore là c'est bon
pour tout c'est bon pour tout le monde
sait ce que c'est moi s'amuse ça me
fascine comme en nutrition n'y avait
aucune nuance si c'est complètement
fascinant mais mettant quelqu'un qui dit
non pas inquiet
mais tant et tant qu'on le sait qui est
il une exagération au niveau du gluten
type l'intolérance au gluten ce
quelqu'un dit au mobile ten même si 1 2
tickets se peut qu est-ce qui peut dire
quelqu'un qui parle de son expérience
c'est ce que j'ai déjà donné un exemple
n'a pas encore que l'alimentation mais
qu'ils utilisent souvent moins quelqu'un
qui viendra pharmacie qui me disait moi
je prends de la myopathie l'okimo dit
que sa mère ait porté à la fin mon ma
réponse à solo c'est good for you où je
suis vraiment contente c'est n'importe
quoi qui va aider pour t'aimons tête des
maux de dos je m'en sacre le chemin
content pour toi que cinq minutes ce qui
est extrêmement différent d'une personne
qui est morte qui me dit hey j'ai vu ce
produit-là ses tablettes les produits
homéopathiques
est ce que tu veux le conseil grosse
différence moi je vais remettre en doute
les chacun un ebe chaque étape de juger
ce qui est bon pour lui le hockey moi je
vois pas aller me dire à quelqu'un était
dans ma cave de prendre ça c'est clair
que ça marche pas et je pense pas que la
communauté scientifique sais pas ce qu'a
fait non plus la france est est-ce qu'on
peut recommander la diète paléo la 10e
c'est tôt où les enfants est-ce qu'on
peut la recommander aux gens la réponse
a peut être non mais ils vont rester
toujours des gens qui y vont l'essayer
devant durer six mois - là je l'essayé
puis moins ça fait la job pour - b good
for you pourtant mieux y avait pas de
problème mais moi je vois pas la
recommander à la personne moyenne très
parce que je sais que ça fera pas la job
tu pile à dieppe
que tu peux recommander si à kehl pour
les gens qui nous écoutent va tandis que
la mère en fait l'enjeu en nutrition on
sait qu'il ya des la nutrition première
est une science qui est très très jeune
ça fait pas si longtemps que ça qu'on
s'intéresse à la nutrition savait pas si
longtemps qu'on fait des grandes études
ou six puits l'enjeu ici dans l'est dans
les études qu'on en alimentation c'est
qu'on va faire beaucoup ce qu'on appelle
des études épidémiologiques romandie
office pas une étude ou que tu vas
prendre des groupes de personnes
choisies au kivu on veut mettre des
leviers at tout on va vous mettre sur
une audi est pile on vous suit pendant
cinq ans c'est très rare qu'on fait
seulement une étude ce qu'on appellerait
contrôlé randomisé et c'est assez rare
qu'on fait sur ce qu'on fait plus tôt
c'est qu'on va regarder qu'est ce que
les gens mangent typiquement on va leur
faire des questionnaires puis ensuite on
voit qu'on va suivre ce pendant des
années où on va regarder
ok tout est à développer un cancer
qu'est ce que tu as mangé dans les dix
dernières années ça fait qu'en général
c'est assez difficile de tirer des
conclusions claires les gens pourquoi
les jeunes pourquoi tu es le diet amène
telles choses ou et s'est fait plus rare
m'attirer des conflits entre états
peuvent rentrer en ligne de compte que
c'est pas contrôler oh et puis un bon
exemple si c'est les gens qui sont comme
les jeunes qui mangent beaucoup plainte
vise le choix soit vegan nous soit
végétarien ou peu importe
souvent pas toujours mais souvent des
gens qui vont aussi aborder d'autres
très bonnes 07 de vie saine fait
qu'amener situe sur le véganisme qui va
les rendre en bonne santé ou c'est le
fait qu'ils fument peau qui font plus de
vélo c'est dur à dire les médicaments
nationale non il s en cache toujours
toujours pas ce que ça veut dire
l'inflammation ça augmente les
formations factices aux faits bref c'est
quoi les conseils qu'on peut donner en
fait ce qu'on sait c'est que toutes les
grandes études sur la nutrition
ils convergent toutes dans le sens
qu'une alimentation qui est très très
riche en végétaux ce sens m pas mal la
meilleure alimentation pour prévenir les
maladies chroniques
puis diminuer le taux de certains
cancers qu'est une alimentation riche en
végétaux ses larges l'outil peut faire
sauter plusieurs façons la diète
méditerranéenne saunion qui a été bien
étudié avec des études intéressantes
bien construite assez longue qui nous
permettent une alimentation qui est
riche en végétaux l'alimentation médecin
n'a ni canton poissons aussi là
poisson ils consomment pas des tonnes de
viande team s'est beaucoup des noix des
huiles végétales et cetera puis on le
voit à l'autre et les gens ont dit il ya
moins d'obésité et moins de maladies
cardiovasculaires il ya un moins de
certains cancers fait c'en est une
l'e10 est végétarienne et végétalienne
s'est dédit à toucy qui amènent des
dédits profil généralement qui sont très
intéressants point de vue de la santé
fait que c'est une saison que c'est
quelque chose qu'on peut dire avec un
niveau de confiance assez élevé une
diète est élevé en végétaux pas
nécessairement pas de viande pas
nécessairement pas de produits
animaliers mais très riche en végétaux
en général c'est quand tu me demande
c'est quoi le conseil que je donne mon
jeune papa support nutritionnel mais
quand les gens me le demande de façon
informelle dans la vie c'est sûr je la
réponse le plus de végétaux possible
genre tu peux pas te tromper trop
concentrées dans le fauteuil pas besoin
de connaître toutes les données puis
toute l'élite détail de nutrition est
une enfant mange plus de végétaux
possible bord de l'eau évitez les
produits transformés cependant les tons
enfants ouais effectivement ça risque de
bien aller pour mettons la plupart des
gens dont le il ya des différentes et on
est déjà présentement qui mangent cet
objet qui se met du beurre dans leur
café puis qui se bourrent de bacon pis
ça va bien 5 en mai mais josé en oeuvre
pour eux ça vaut bien se connecte mais
en général oui je pense qu'on peut on
n'a pas besoin de connaître tous les
détails comment ce qu'on peut dire aux
gens manger le plus de végétaux possible
mangez pas du junk parce que dit jeudi
attendre des derniers boulette de
burgers et je pourrai manger des frites
et vegan ya des gens qui deviennent des
gannes prennent du poids
ça va pas bien leur affaire parce que
une chose de demander des végétaux mais
si tu manges la crap john coates pour
mieux dans le livre des ventes justement
il en parle beaucoup qui lui prend
beaucoup de suspense que kylie lui-même
végétaliens ou mentaux il est peut-être
pas loin je pense que tu es un peu comme
moins dans le sens où kyste comme un
espèce de semis végétarien fonctionnel
noms qu'il ya et c'est de consommer de
la viande plus le ton
alors de façon exceptionnelle à
l'occasion entre les dix que les
végétaliens qui les gens qui ont une
annotation plein buzz
on remarque une diminution de 25% des
maladies cardiovasculaires mais qu'un
vegan qu'il fait mal
il défend une augmentation de 30 % si on
l'avait gagné au resto tout le temps tu
peux pas nier ni vegan pipi ferme en ce
moment c'est un peu on est on est pas si
bête doit phd en est conscient mais il
ya un boom en ce moment on il ya un
momentum en ce moment d'intérêt pour les
diètes landaise et le véganisme en tant
que telle non ce que personnellement je
trouve extraordinaire le sait une des
affaires les plus excitantes que j'ai
connu personnellement dissidents dans le
domaine de la santé dernières années sur
ce vraiment cool
on s'assoit haute mais là le danger en
ce moment c'est que les gens
s'intéressent à ça mais ils sont pas
nécessairement encore bien informées au
potier pour moi c'est ça avec moi je
vois des gens qui vont à l'épicerie puis
qui sont comme des jeux message tout les
produits le lit boulette de burgers les
saucisses de tofu blizzard a formé à
fond c'est la cochonnerie ça c'est
l'enfer du jeu comme on mange pas
semaine c'est dégueulasse tracker
factice à ips allemande un certain taux
de responsabilité aussi dalit choqué
c'est un faux nous on essaie le plus
possible de ne pas avoir d'aliments
transformés ces d'aliments préfabriqué
des jeunes c'est déjà congelés mettons
et une cuisine et le plus possible ce
que je pense sur un conseil que je peux
donner à tout le monde je suis né est-ce
que tu connais marjolaine mercier ouais
ouais je suis ici good ménager la chèvre
et manger le choix je le mélange tout le
temps où manger la chèvre mais ça peut
plus ménager la chèvre et le ksk propose
lp lnb retour d'une aktion sbs qui
propose aussi une alimentation végétale
minimalement transformer donc évidemment
que tout le john gibson a mangé le moins
possible cela marche pareil le loisir
débit puisque rio c'est bon tabarnouche
le christ correct d'en manger mais faut
que tu en manges le moins possible
qui était cette cuisine quand tu es
capable il était d'acheter justement des
produits qui ont rajouté un paquet de
sucre paquet si elle ne danse pas quand
tu combine les deux là beaucoup de
végétaux le moins junk food possible et
ça commence à donner quoi que pas mal
d'ailleurs pour la majorité du monde
si on parle la diète c'est au web
premièrement lorsque tu nous disais que
tu avais tu avais étudier le code
beaucoup quand même
j'ai fait j'ai fait un épisode là dessus
pour la saison 3 qui est encore diffusée
je fais une grosse recherche là dessus
puis c'est lui le sujet s'est basé sur
quoi puis un couesque bastien ou non
ouais contrat super bien des questions
dans le fond c'est que ladite cet argent
pour ceux qui sont peut-être pas au
courant c'est le gros hits de 2018
vraiment l'autre si c'est un mouvement
planétaire
c'est une diète ou le principe c'est une
marge de plus de gros possible
ok le gros sous toutes ses formes et de
consommer le moins possible de glucides
et idéalement aucun de l'ue sync est
donc qu'est ce qu'on va manger mais on
va manger tous les gros donc évidemment
il ya le grand animal du strict des
choses comme ça
les gros végétaux donc les huiles
végétales d'aidé de l'avocat des choses
comme ça fait marcher dessus
est ce que tu manges pas si tous les
glucides donc évidemment c'est tout ce
qu'ils payent un pad céréales mes soucis
les légumineuses souci des fruits fruits
comment g de fruits laisse quand même si
chrysler et le principal air de tout ça
c'est que ça vienne 1920 dans les années
après 1920 tunisienne qui avaient été
testées pour les enfants épileptiques et
on se rendait compte que des enfants qui
avait tout essayé pour l'épilepsie
on les mettait sur une diète cette
agence a semblé diminuer le nombre de
crise de convulsions et c'était rester
seule idée et là ça a comme fin des
résurgences depuis peut-être pas prêt
sur deux trois quatre cinq ans ou le
tout d'un coup c'est comme il ya des
gens qui disent ben moi je pense je fais
sur perdre du poids je veux ce même
prévenir les maladies chroniques on
entend même pour le corps pour comme
traiter le cancer ou prévenir le cancer
tout cas c'est la liste de bien faire et
comme l'ongle comme le mur fait le yo
comme une résurgence de tout ça mais y'a
pas plus d'études sur le sujet si comme
il ya un regain d'intérêt
mais toutes ces affirmations le qui
disent que ça fait exprès xi sont plus
supportés par des données probantes
donc on a pas beaucoup amélioré la
situation des militants des bulletins
qu'on en parle il n'y a pas d'étude qui
ont été faites encore là dessus il y en
a quelques-unes métiers les études qui
ont été faites ces exemples est ce qu'on
parle du poids mais ton sûr
une diète qui est très très faible en
glucides la réponse est oui tu passes du
port très rapidement à court terme comme
à peu près n'importe quel 10e très
strictes il le dire de cette audience
très restrictif un parti que les à des
bons duos très restrictif puis les gens
y perdre du poids beaucoup la court
terme mais par contre est ce qu'ils
perdent du poids vraiment
significativement à long terme jusqu'en
tous les regards dans un à deux ans se
rend compte que la différence finalement
n'est pas une grosse différence
s'effectue prise pendant un à deux ans
pour perdre du poids tempère un peu puis
au bout de ligne topo perdu tant de
poids
on entend dire que c'est capable de
renverser des maladies comme le diabète
de type 2
moi j'ai pas de problème avec soin en
autant qu'ils peuvent le prouver en ce
moment ils peuvent pas le prouver
on entend dire que ça prévient le cancer
ont saisi aucune preuve de ce que ça à
kerry un paquet de maladie aucune preuve
de ce buzz comme garde faites votre
travail et les boys 9 fait lève aux
études la pression je pourrais faire des
affirmations là dessus parce que le
sucre s'est rendu le nouveau hall
il me semble que quand j'étais petit
c'était les gros cons éviter ce
versement
mais ces cellules ce bien commun ce que
ça fonctionne adam société la santé le
sait que les gens veulent des réponses
faciles mais que veulent pas se faire
donner des réponses comme tous
conscience depuis tantôt là on est dans
la nuance t on parle de et les dyades
vegan c'est intéressant c'est pas bon
tout le monde sait ça c'est le genre de
discours on devrait avoir les gens ils
veulent pas se perdre les gens veulent
se faire des cocktails aliments ou tel
groupe d'aliments qui pense dit plus
jamais mangé en plus jamais avant
l'ennemi numéro 1 jetez le gras salés
pas manger de gourou plein m'emmener
dans les dernières années c'est devenu
le sucre ne vaut plus manger du sucre le
monde aime s'occuper des aliments
drastiquement comme soit parce que c'est
plus simple que de se poser les vraies
questions
c'est beaucoup les gens trop près
accepté ce pays accepte pas quand tu dis
jus d'orange et comme du coup je
souffrais taxi père d'une enfant j'ai
beaucoup de contradictions et beaucoup
de contradictions dans le domaine de la
santé
fascinant puis encore le regarde se
bourrer de produits qui sont très très
très riche en sucre c'est pas bon est ce
que ça veut dire qu'il faut couper les
fruits puis les légumineuses je pense
très beau c'est encore le ya un manque
de nuance c'est de pas faire la
distinction entre les glucides ou encore
le suc libre ce qui ajouté
mais les gens ne veulent pas aller dans
nuancent ils veulent se faire des coupes
le choc ici plus simple que ça et ça
c'est malheureux
parce que ce que tu dis c'est ce qui se
passe et le turban des sikhs
tu vas voir ainsi que ça va être les
grosses pas bon là le succès probant
presque ma belle et grosse pas si pire
finalement parce que le problème c'était
les gras trans
ah ok oui mais les gras saturés en eau
les gras saturés c'est les grands
animaux c'est pas si pire finalement
mais ce principe est ce possible mais sa
bouche les artères appareils en eau non
ça bouge plus artères bluff finalement
tu regardais études oui sa bouche les
artères et c'est compliqué en
tabarnouche le la science à ce niveau là
qu'il ya pas un aliment qu'il faut
couper ou un groupe d'aliments qu'il
faut couper c'est vraiment tout est une
question d'équilibré
c'est par rapport à la diète et qui est
aux gens tant des intérêts du québec
pas longtemps au québec se connaissaient
[Rires]
bouchard qu'est ce que disait il y avait
un éviter qu'il ne parlait le dj taux
plein dit à quel point que pour elle
savait était magique émeutes ont perdu
du pos média présente ce médecin l'a
fait et il est à présent temps et une
médecin il vient parler de tout et dans
mon épisode d'ailleurs
oui le dr bourgeois je vais très bien
mart ou de ce que l'entrevue que j'ai
entendu à part les trois sénateurs
anecdotique son expérience personnelle
tech
c'est quand même un peu trompeur des
invités un médecin qui se pose est une
sommité dans quelque chose pour
déconnecter donné mais qui parle juste
de son expérience personnelle
en fait je pense pas qu'apple juste
c'est aussi la période c'est comme moi
je l'écouté cette entrevue leur dont tu
me parles tu mon sujet les écouter et
leur pilote
j'avais envie du genre de sauter par la
fenêtre d'impression moi j ai fait une
entrevue avec elle pour mon émission
d'un coup on s'entend sur à peu près
tout évidemment on se rend compte que c
est assez nuancés dans ses propos à des
enfants qui sont intéressantes et pas
dans les extrêmes elle non plus partie
seagate tout est une question d'angle
aussi d'entrevue puis tout seul ça
dépend comment tu poses des questions
pis ces piges je dis ce jeu c'est
toujours ça en toute humilité médecin
moi je te proposait de la santé si
j'interviens au procès la santé je
poserai pas les mêmes questions que
directeur de radio va y poser je vois
ici d'aller décortiquer un peu le propos
puis les nuances finalement en discutant
avec elle c'est comme a dit a dit non
non moi je veux pas que les gens
arrêtent les fruits je veux pas que les
gens coupent les légumineuses puis tout
cela dit je veux pas sauter puis a dit
je veux pas que le monde mange du
véhicule qui met du beurre dans leur
café tout s'effectue dès fois s'étendant
sur six ça dépend toujours des questions
qu'on pose à la personne de les chefs
d'antenne les chefs d'antenne les gens
qui ont des micros à québec c'est les
experts de faire comme de faire passer
leurs points de vue en entrevue t2 poser
les questions ultra rhétorique qui met
la personne
en entrevue dans un coin vraiment du
style à sortir plus à personne même si a
réussi à sortir c'est question après
question pour que la personne n'en
l'auto sorte avec cette impression là de
dire non en fait je te fait raison c'est
de la radio d'opinion pleut on va juste
précisé une autre séquence où des radios
québec l'on peut de toutes les races
tous les radios de québec puisqu'il fait
de l'attitude de la super bonne radio au
québec n'ont de raison des coûts de
bande parfois que des fois je trouve ça
quand même les divertissait fossé divers
si tu le vois au deuxième degré le
stupre à ce compliment c'est très drôle
mais la radio d'opinion chez moi ce que
je reproche à ce type de radio l'appui
ils savent pas ce que je suis déjà allé
je leur ai dit en pleine face
il était pas mal d'accord le problème
c'est que vous avez avec votre opinion
pivote opinion devient plus comme un
fait avéré de ses pilotes du monde qui
spéculent dans une entrevue pendant cinq
minutes de temps sur un sujet qui
connaissent pas et la caisse quel goût
l'auditeur exposé retenir de tueuse gens
ce qu'était discuté le stud est vrai
enfin ou c'est juste l'opinion d'une ou
deux personnes
c'est un gros problème en ce moment dans
le domaine de la science mais de la
santé les gens ont tendance beaucoup à
mélanger opinion effet les gens aiment
se croire à leur opinion plus
qu'incertain fait ses preuves un des
plus grandes menaces c'est en ce moment
non pas pour la halle pour la culture
scientifique populaire moi quand j'étais
jeune
je me souviens qu'on disait tout le
temps ça c'est prouvé scientifiquement
c'est vrai on dit plus haut on dit ok on
dirait que prouver scientifiquement
c'est ouais mais l'on les postures
pénibles sapir changer petits sandres et
quelle est la preuve scientifique à la
moine puis entrait comme si toute
éventuelle opinion - ben en fait c'est
que probablement qui en exagérer un peu
mais c'est à dire que le parlement de
dire que quelque chose est prouvé
scientifiquement on le dit plus pour une
bonne raison c'est que jamais rien de
prouvé scientifiquement soi même ça
marche la science le la science n'est
pas de prouver des enfants et pas de
vérité scientifique ou rien là c'est
juste que j'ai été sentie n'avait pas de
vérité scientifique fait que l'état en
mettant les trous noirs
non non pas du tout parce que je dirais
on n'est pas capables d'aller dans un
trou noir n'est pas capable d'observer
un jeudi comme kim aime le hockey que
pourrait aller dedans puis dire je l'aï
des trous noirs stabaek houle sera pas
plus une preuve
la science est une démarche qui nous
permet de vérifier certaines
affirmations qu'on fait on n'est jamais
capable de prouver quelque chose à 100%
si on fait des théories demander quand
les théories se tiennent depuis qu'on
est capable de démontrer
expérimentalement que les choses qu'on
affirme se vérifie constamment comme des
choses en physique entre autant physique
que l'on est capable de dire des
affaires de jean coraline on a des
niveaux de certitudes extrêmement prédit
des événements avec une précision
exactement avec là on est petit on n'est
pas dans la preuve tant que ça mais on
nie comme modèle se tient très très bien
fait qu'on dit plus vraiment ça c'est
prouvé scientifiquement mais al'inverse
là on est comme tomber dans l'auto posés
le long de tommy dans le poser aussi
comme diot plus aucune vérité
scientifique et plus aucune preuve de
plus rien il ya des gens qui disent moi
la science je fais plus confiance assure
les scientifiques sont tues tu as acheté
sont toutes vendues sont tous corrompus
sont dans le champ qui s'étaient retirés
fait que j'ai l'impression qu'on est un
peu dans l'adolescence de la science
dans la mesure où le tout d'un coup les
gens ont accès à l'information sur
internet et ses thérapies le il rejette
systématiquement certaines affaires en
science n'est pas tout mais les
certaines affaires
c'est pour ça qu'on voit des mouvements
anti vaccin c'est pour ça qu'on voit des
mouvements anti ogm ou des choses comme
sauter des choses qui sont complètement
irrationnel mais les gens ont comme
besoin de dieu pour se réapproprier un
peu la science dans un sens ce qu'il
faut espérer c'est que d'ici comme chez
pro 10 15 20 et allemagne on va revenir
à quelque chose de plus
oui exactement où les gens vont faire
comme ok ya pas de vérité scientifique
mais jodie fait qu'ils sont vraiment
très bien démontré
puis un moment donné mon opinion avons
peut-être pas grand-chose à travers tout
seul la vérité des foyers des
désillusions de des bosses je prends par
exemple n'aurait peut-être plus de
thonier mettons à foxnews avons évité un
scientifique climato-sceptiques puis un
scientifique qui fait partie de la
majorité des scientifiques pensent que
le réchauffement climatique c'est réel
psychose éperdument legault on a des
beaux mais le la représentation c'est 50
c'est ce que tu vois ce qui est pour eux
mais en réalité c'est 99 points de 6 1%
des scientifiques qui sont climato
sceptiques pour qu'ils soient
représentatifs faudrait qu'à 99
scientifique pour un climato sceptiques
seuls des beauty sauf que mais là on
pense qu'encore des débats des endroits
où ce que c'est réglé ça porte un nom
s'appelle le feq balance ça vient du
fait que quand les journalistes sont
paumés les journalistes dans leur
formation ils se font dire que il faut
qu'il montre un peu il faut que qui
aborde le sujet de manière neutre
donc il faut qu'un vol par exemple si eu
un accident de voiture dans rue pour
qu'elles vont la personne qui qui
conduit telle voiture l'autre voiture
vous qu'à voir le policier qui vont
donner les différents points de vue très
bien comme ça et ce disque on a couvert
de manière neutre parce qu'on a eu le
pin et on a eu la vie de tout le monde
le problème c'est que la science po
demain ça marche si c'est pas comme on
demandait à un paquet de monde qui on va
voir c'est quoi les points de vue très
con comme tu mentionnes c'est facile de
trouver un expert qui va te donner
n'importe quel point de vue sur
n'importe quoi
si j'osais je pourrais te donner des
exemples à projeter loti et un médecin
au québec qui fait des injections de
pensée de guérison de ses feuilles prix
e-prix dans une seringue bien jacques ce
moment aurait il pris dans une seringue
qui est injecté dans les veines du monde
pour injecter des pensées positives axée
sur la praille sfax et ça c'est que la
prime c'est un point de vue c'est toi
c'est un médecin si une personne qui ont
un diplôme sur son humeur donc ils
méritent qu'on les écoute
non c'est pas demain ça c'est du fait
que balancer injection de placebo fond
ben oui si c'est le même point de vue
c'est que d'aider des experts appelés
les gens me vois pas faire le game et
j'en fais avec mes doigts des experts
qui vont dire que les changements
climatiques ça n'existe pas tu vas
trouver des experts comme ça le problème
c'est qu'ils représentent une infime
minorité et souvent ce ne sont pas des
vraies expériences
climatologues s'arrête des géologues où
ça va être des ingénieurs du monde qui
sont même pas des experts du sujet cette
enveloppe brune anti la tête d'une
compagnie des fois même pas inventé le
niveau de déception ce pas le bon mot
justice déception en anglais mais les
niveaux d'illusions qu'on peut se faire
nous mêmes dans notre tête c'est mon
genre contre j'en rencontre constamment
des scientifiques que j'écoute par
l'ippj comme ok ces gens là comme on
dirait qu'ils sont jamais ayons jamais
eu un cours de sciences dans leur vie
et pourtant c'est des gens qui ont des
doctorats en sciences des chercheurs est
petit comme mémé mike oddih ou qui ont
fait leurs études ces absurdités mesures
sont en train d'inventer des concepts
l'un des facteurs mais est-ce qui étudie
en sciences hommes et en médecine ou en
pharmacie
est-ce que ça encourage esprit critique
ou ses dents magazine et d'apprendre par
coeur le plus d'affaires possible en
théorie ça devrait encourager l'esprit
critique en pratique pas tout le temps
parce que les balles les fondements de
l'esprit critique n'a pas besoin d'être
scientifique pour avoir ce tu peux avoir
en team j'en rencontre a tout les gens
d'utiliser les gens qui ceux qui
s'intéressent au scepticisme ou à
l'esprit critique en général c'est des
gens qui ont tendance à douter dans la
vie non tu vont pas prendre pour acquis
ce que les gens leur dise bon dos mais
ok tu me dit à la fin je vais poser des
questions je vois c'est de casser un peu
ton argumentaire pour inciter les
creuser là dedans puis après ça que je
dois faire mes propres vérifications
plutôt que c'est sur l'esprit critique
dans le fond si c'est pas accepter pour
du cash ce qu'on nous dit mais des gens
qui rentrent en sciences et qui n'ont
aucun fondement l'esprit critique et ça
donne des gens qui vont arriver avec des
diplômés et ses terrains puis qu'ils
vont dire des enfants qui n'ont aucun
bon sens puis moi j'en rencontre
constamment des pharmaciens des
nutritionnistes des médecins des
biochimistes des chimistes et physiciens
qui disent des affaires complètement
absurde et qui ont une absence totale
l'esprit critique mais ils ont étudié en
sciences 20 mai que ça a l'air d'être
comme contrainte sarah d'être
contradictoire mais c'est que souvent
les études en science vont pas tout à
prendre nécessairement toi-même matin
à te forger ton esprit critique t on
espère que ça va se faire mais c'est pas
garanti city c'est pour ça que moi je
milite beaucoup pour l'enseignement de
l'esprit critique chez les jeunes dès le
plus jeune âge parce que si on apprend
aux jeunes à les former l'esprit
critique mais peut-être qu'on va éviter
tout ce petit bordel plus tard l'ancien
on espère en tout cas
pour prendre la pose de ce mal à
rebondir serait sur les jeunes
tu disais d'instruire les enfants avoir
un sens critique plus de bonheur dans
leur vie ça me fait penser ma soeur
marie lou qui va sûrement coûté ce
podcast la même salle écoute pas tous
les podcasts mais celui-là je l'aimé
soit on va l'écouter elle a se faisait
reprocher par ses professeurs au
primaire de poser trop de questions
totalement parce que était curiosité
elle avait une curiosité scientifique
l'étang médecine aujourd'hui dans la
veine curiosité scientifique qui était
jamais satisfaite par les sujets par la
limitation dans les cadres ce pour moi c
c
ces critiques comme problème de de taper
ses doigts d'un enfant qui pose trop de
questions puis ce n'est pas parce qu'à
comprenez lentement c'était parce
qu'elle voulait savoir plus sur les
sujets et la place de l'encourager à
faire ça on l'a critiqué de faire ce
calcul se gagne à une citation de lui
que je suis à la fin de mon livre ce qui
dit tous les enfants des scientifiques
et d'enfoncer qu'on éteint cette
étincelle lâcher la plupart des enfants
en a certaines qui conserve ce à travers
leur vie mais la plupart on les taille
mais une live scientifique parce que les
enfants se posent après quatre questions
et la caisse qui va déterminer s'ils
vont continuer à se poser autant de
questions puis tout seul qui ait
sceptiques de nature finalement être
critique etc
c'est beaucoup ce qu'ils vont avoir
comme type de réponse sexy quand il pose
une question tu dit ailleurs mais ça
part mal situés dans des réponses toutes
faites près manche est facile ou
extérieur tu dis parce que oui et c'est
heureux d'amener l'enfant se découragent
puis finit par se dire bon mais coudon
semaine ça marche est ce qui est un peu
dommage c'est que des fois on enseigne
beaucoup aux enfants ce qu'ils doivent
penser et on leur dit voici ce que tu
dois penser sur tel ou tel ou tel sujet
plutôt que de les amener à se demander
comment on pense c'est comment on
réfléchit comme si qu'on se pose des
questions comme comment on trouve les
réponses ici puis une des façons
principal de développer l'esprit
critique chez les jeunes cela renseigne
et la méthode scientifique de la méthode
scientifique pour compliquer le c5 et à
placer comme tu observes dû poser
question tu formule des hypothèses
ce fait certaines certains tests
certaines vérifications puis à la fin
mais tu arrives avec une réponse qui est
problème est beaucoup mieux que tu as
deviné que tu avais fait au début utile
cc je soupçon l'ap lecture dans notre
vie dans une certaine mesure anti sans
s'en rendre compte
mais quand tu étais capable de le
montrer formellement aux jeunes c'est
voici comment ça marche plus voici
comment ce que les scientifiques qui
sont capables de déterminer que
qu'un satellite qu'on envoie dans
l'espace qui va se rendre sur mars la
voici comment est ce que ça fonctionne
mais c'est avec la même méthode
scientifique que toi tu es capable de
comprendre qu'au bâton au grille-pain
fonctionne c'est qu'à pas de médecine
dentaire des enfants c'est
extraordinaire mais malheureusement les
temps on peut se faire puis comment tu
l'as fait le problème doivent vient de
récemment parce qu'ils savaient pas ça
vient pas des professeurs je pense pas
moi je pense que les preuves sont super
banque c'est le problème des eaux puis
comment on rectifie city moi je prends
un expert la demande si je suis loin de
penser que je connais vraiment le
domaine de l'éducation pour tous à ce
que les profs font super job
moi je pense qu'on a une excellente
éducation scientifique ou six mais je
pense que peut-être que ce qui manque ce
jeu c'est vraiment mon est mon opinion
le jeu l'annoncent d'avancé mais je
pense que ce qui manque peut-être c2d
peut-être faire réaliser aux jeunes deux
fois que la science est vraiment dans
notre quotidien
premièrement et puis ça se fait avec des
exemples concrets
ok puis deuxièmement aussi c'est de
réaliser que la science finalement ça
s'applique à peu près tu peut
l'appliquer à tout et donc forcément que
si un kid se fait de ce fait vendre une
bébelle un jouet quelques en temps une
annonce à la télévision il peut
appliquer les mêmes concepts qui a
appris sur la méthode sentier qui veut
appliquer les mêmes concepts pour
essayer de juger 6 consolider ou l'objet
qu'on attendrait de lui vendre ses
valide ou pas fake
moi je pense qu'il manque peut-être doit
pas être quelque chose de pratique aux
pratiques là dedans c'est une question
de culture
je pense que c'est juste pas dans notre
culture d'enseignés ça ça se fait
peut-être plus dans d'autres pays vous
dis je sais pas trop le mais moi je
pense que c'est ce qui manque c'est un
manque carrément un cours qui on
donnerait aux jeunes voudraient ainsi de
quoi le cocon donne aux jeunes de ses
fondements de l'esprit critique fait
appeler ça autrement la piscine ont
accusé attrayant je m'en vais dans mon
cours de fondement de l'esprit critique
exacte et à appeler ça comme tu veux le
titre c'est pas un problème mais ça
devrait être soit en tant que tel c'est
parce que ce que la littérature nous dit
c'est que il faut montrer une méthode il
faut la prendre il faut montrer aux
jeunes comment faire présentement le
problème c'est qu'on assume qu'un jeune
qui passe à travers tout le système
scolaire
à la fin de son système scolaire il va
avoir développé tous les outils
d'autodéfense intellectuelle pour se
protéger contre les fakes news puis
contre la la baule shit santé et autres
non désolé mais c'est pas vrai on peut
pas assumer ce il faut que tu leur
donnes des outils il faut que tu l'aies
phase pratique et l'accès à mon humble
avis ça manque un petit peu en ce moment
actions pourraient s'améliorer
j'ai l'impression qu'on est appelé à
choisir son camp dès fois dans le
parcours protocolaire entre les ordres
ou les sciences et souvent c'est comme
telle option à l'option obepi c'est
c'est des choses qui peuvent être sport
ensemble de type récemment des trains ou
l'eau dans la vie puis moi g
j'ai découvert que j'aimais les sciences
ou du moins je me suis rappelé que
jamais les sciences
quand j'écoutais la série cosmos on
explique ce jeune japonaise un podcast
j'apprends la forme intéressant puis je
voulais en savoir plus le ch écouter
toutes les vidéos possible de 9° récents
sur youtube que je pouvais trouver le
ch'ti vêtements la pop le le sait comme
je l'éteins c'est le feu hier priorité
mais je me suis souvenu après se cache t
j ce n'est pas les jo je vais demander
que je voulais plus tard j'ai déjà dit
par un période de ma vie que je veux est
astrophysicien s'écoule pigeard je vais
faire des expériences ya également une
expérience pilote si j'avais comme tout
oublié ces disparus quand même quand je
t'ai rencontrée c'était plus belle non
parce que moi après son secondaire au
cégep c'était comme les ors puis la
musique subi piste est subi mais j'ai eu
cette étincelle scientifique le pilot
maintenant est réapparu puis je me rends
compte que ce projet ou l'autre
prétendante à dire des fois mon lit
sciences ou ses amis palois ancienne
licence à m'intéresse pas mais si dit
c'est pas juste des abstractions lassé
des choses pas pratiques vont servir
dans vraie vie aussi
écoute ça me rappelle tellement ce que
tu dis là pis si ce genre de prise de
conscience l'onpl of l'on peut faire en
sorte que les plus de gens là ils m'ont
dit que ça règlerait des problèmes parce
que c'est ça c'est pas tout le monde qui
va étudier dans le domaine des sciences
c'est correct on veut pas que toutes les
jeunes deviennent scientifiques les jo
c'est quand même des carrières qui sont
arides si les grecs sont longues aussi
des longues études et c'est heureux
c'est un certain type de job qui demande
un certain type de personnalité ou si tu
sais ça fait pas pour tout le monde
mais ces points importants on s'en fout
de tout si je veux dire si on pouvait
faire réaliser aux kits bio aux adultes
puis tout le monde que la science c'est
100 % de ce qui nous entoure
pis que dans le fond on peut tout
l'utiliser puis l'appliquer dans notre
quotidien qui sont veuves prendre juste
conscience de ça on trie près bien plus
sur la science créé oui bon je mets pas
plus de moi je pense même pas qu'on a
besoin de plus de scientifiques dans ma
vie je pense qu'on aurait plus de gens
qui prennent conscience de l'importance
de la science dans leur vie tous les
jours tu sais déjà
les contrats
très de quelqu'un qui m'était
scientifiquement dans le fond d'avoir
une formation c'est tout elle comptait
lire
écrire mais en science de presse de base
sont les flux et compassé langage le un
minimum de ces deux là c'est ce qu'on
appelle la littératie scientifique gis
hockey au canada on aime on se plaît à
dire qu'on est dans les meilleurs pays
en termes de littératie scientifique le
défaut il ya des sondages sopi on se
rend compte qu'on est dans les meilleurs
mais en passant un monde j'ai déjà fait
l'exercice le monde mais il y avait une
nouvelle qui était sorti et peut-être de
trois ans qui disait le canada est
numéro 1 sur 13 pays en termes de
littératie scientifique puis genre 4,4 à
les voir le sondage à quoi ça correspond
dell qui c'est assez pathétique
l'honneur d'être le meilleur le sais pas
où tu le joues c'est comme c'était
quelque chose du genre
43% des gens sont capables de lire une
nouvelle scientifique dans le journal
c'est loin d'un article scientifique
dans une revue littéraire stioui le jeu
normalement on espérait que 100 % de la
population peut se lire une nouvelle
scientifique dans le journal
parce que dans le journaliste écrit pour
que n'importe qui puisse comprendre et
que c'était juste 43% du monde peut
comprendre c'est que c'est pas terrible
fait que la littératie scientifique la
culture scientifique ça ça c'est un gros
problème ça manque évidemment une
question d'intérêt aussi là dedans tu
sais comme beaucoup de gens rejettent du
revers de la main comme te dis qu'ils
disent aux mauriciens j'aime pas où tu
peux pas me dire que tu aimes pas à la
science jose est un cellulaire dentelle
vip thème ce que ton cellule a fait
thème la science
this is it ok c'est juste que tu
réalises pote te jettes te jamais porté
prête attention à tout tout ce que la
science constituer ou apportent dans ton
cellulaire qui est écrit que tu crois
pas tu crois pas dans les sciences au
ton téléphone c'est comme ça c'est la
taxe oui exact c'est encore pire les
gens qui sont dans le déni alisme
scientifique du musée moller je fais
plus confiance à la science du tout seul
ah ouais ok c'est bon maintenant on va
faire la liste de toutes les affaires
dans vie que classions s'il ya un
problème qui rendent aux portes du
paradis puis de tâter
[Rires]
ces enfants de dieu que je crois pas
annuler ses brevets mais qui est ce que
toi dans ton cheminement avec justement
on à lévis il pour ce qui est des
actions sur youtube
le petit garçon posé trop de questions
alors que ce toit j'imagine que c'est un
petit peu autobiographique
c'est quelque chose que tu t'es fait
dire à ce que c'est quelque chose que
toi tu as vécu
ben oui ben oui totalement puis mon
petit tu parles de ta soeur quant au
moins j'étais stocker de l'eau le sujet
tel kit qui posait des questions posées
a peut-être un peu trop de questions à
l'école ce qui posait des questions que
visiblement le prof était pas content de
se faire poser et 18 comme exemple un
exemple qui très très clair dans ma tête
c'est moi j'allais dans une école
religieuse qui je me souviens puis on a
les pieds à là on m'a laissé faire ce
qu'on fait c'est pas parce que mes
parents interreligieux nettement l'était
pas vraiment mais c'était sur les
lectures qui puis je me suis d'abord
demandé à mener notre prof nous parler
de la genèse et puis tout comme le monde
avait été créée puis j'ai juste demandé
aux profs comme mais les dinosaures sont
ou dans votre histoire
elle avait été insulté la de ce que j
avais demandé de tactique
moi je t'ai acheté cet enfant là mais
mais mais je pense que c'est honnêtement
la plupart des kits je pense la plupart
des kits se pose beaucoup de questions
mais ils ont peut-être pas tout
l'environnement nécessairement pour
développer ses curiosités je comprends
puis quand tu fais tout un livre pour
pour les enfants j'imagine que tu parles
aussi aux parents à travers le livre
pour l'heure je réalise là mon premier
type existaient avant ma foi je
m'adresse aux jeunes mais mais mais
moitié moins quand j'écris le pharmacien
en 2012
je me suis adressé aux jeunes je me suis
adressé aux gens de ma génération
ce qu'il ya un paquet de référence de
culture pop idée de jack que problème
est que certaines personnes ne
comprennent pas nécessairement mais dix
fois plus qu'en mai
mais il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui a
maintenant je me sens trahi beaucoup de
jeunes qui aiment sur ce que je fais
c'est de la bd et puis tout ça fait que
je m'adresserai jamais un public en
particulier sur la vérité ça m'intéresse
pas de me dire le je veux m'adresser aux
six et douze en direct - dans la ville
je me faire expliquer les affaires comme
si j'avais 5 ans parce que je suis pas
quelqu'un qui comprend vite les enfants
n'en vis pas comme ça j'ai jamais
compris les affaires vite j'ai besoin de
faire expliquer des affaires trois
quatre cinq fois puis d'or lire deux
trois fois la même affaire à 24 avec moi
quand je parle aux gens je leur parle
comme s'ils étaient des enfants
si pour être condescendance pas pour
être catherine eising c'est parce que
moins seulement que j'ai besoin de
comprendre quand j'écris un livre pour
enfants de mon point de vue c'est pas
très différent d'écrire un livre pour
adulte tien juste beaucoup moins de mots
c'est dans mon lit peut enfin il ya une
phrase par page dans les lits pour un
tuyau peut-être six par page
mais sans doute ce que beaucoup de
français non moi je m'égare tellement de
gens qui viennent
le plus beau compliment que je reçois ce
que des gens viennent me voir et m'ont
aidé à y lire mettez les gelées l'ip je
sais pas pourquoi je commets goodness
moi j'écris pour les gens qui aiment pas
le lire parce que moi quand j'étais
jeune ce qui m'interpelle il s'était pas
des textes de saint ennemond ce qui me
tape à l'oeil
c'était j'écoutais des dessins animés
comme il était une fois la vie pts ce
que l'on voyait les les cellules dans le
corps steady bonhomme qui se promenaient
petit moins ça ça me parle ce genre
d'affaires le fait que j'essaie juste de
reproduire le même modèle mais seulement
à penser cela
la façon d'intéresser des gens qui sont
profs qui sont pas intéressés sable à ce
genre d'affaires le sait souvent les
jeunes qui ont besoin de s'y intéresser
le plus oui j'ai l'impression oui parce
que le plus gros danger dans mon affaire
le sait ça serait de ccum prêcher à des
convertis
c'est comme si on le oui c'est ça puis
quelque chose qui m'intéresse vraiment
politis et que l'allemagne et c'est
delphine simon mettre mon site web lieu
du monde qui même que mon site web store
depuis un moment donné mais j'ai comme
un fan bei sont vos tirs qui me lisent
pinkies moi tout ce que je vois dire
vont être d'accord avec ce mois sa
maîtrise post enfin le ca m'interesse
pas pantoute
moi je veux aller chercher le monde qui
ont peut-être pas d'intérêt pour les
sujets en tant que telle ou sous des
gens que je rejoindrai pas normalement
au mois ses seules vraies des chips et
sur le coureur de ce que j'essaie de
faire avec si j'essaie de le faire à
travers différentes plateformes j'essaie
de faire en sorte que le monde fasse
comme i'm moi je n'aurais jamais pensé
dans ma vie que j'irai une conférence
sur la santé
coline que ça me fait plaisir de me
faire dire cela parce que ces gens là le
sont sauf en tabarnouche à aller
chercher
bakhit y aller tu parlé d'aller votre
bon coeur santos a mené un autre alain
il va chercher une frange de la
population qui s'intéresse pas aux
assauts d'habitude c'est extraordinaire
ce qui fait que j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration pour lui il n'ya pas le
même public que moi moi j'ai mon public
d'autres personnes qui ont d'autres
publics qui fait qu il faut aller
chercher les gens différentes façons
c'est moi je le fais avec le mot je le
fais avec des jo qui sont des fois un
peu limite
c'est mon style de chacun il sapera
beaucoup différentes vulgarisateur qui
ont une approche un peu différente
est ce que c'est une mission qui durera
portée des fois t'es quand tu vois
maintenant les réactions qu'elle ment
violente que les gens vont quasiment
violente qui tisser des réseaux sociaux
puis je pense que même des fois tu
réponds aux gens respectueux août jean
pas au début j'essaie de répondre à 100
% les gens inquiets des allemands c'est
moi c'est ma mission depuis j'ai créé le
pharmacien en 2012 là j'ai essayé de
répondre à 100 % les commentaires les
rov serov faut nettement parce que le
monde qu'ils sont maudits
il parle bien plus taxées ce qui est
difficile puisque c'est une mission qui
est dur à porter wii qui j'ai vraiment
passé proche de leur chez eux à
plusieurs reprises puis c'est souvent
les gens font comme itunes store le ya
rien qui doit te déranger le monde qui
t'appelle des noms petit
non parce que je suis un psychopathe
quoi les gens non jean moulin de me
faire insulter
qui de me faire traiter de non plus
j'aime pas ça tombe dans le personnel se
mettant quelqu'un avance des choses que
tu ici qui est scientifiquement ça tient
pas la route bas et dans charme
étiquette attaquent personnellement ça
fait toujours mal moi j'adore la
critique constructive d'un qui je
l'accueille puis même je le dis aux gens
je dis critiqué - pu trouver les forêts
denses que je dis quand ça arrive ça
arrive le sujet
oui me dont j'écris une bd sur un sujet
puis le mans nice va avoir un doute le
jean qui est une profession je
connaissais même pas le genre à un
ingénieur en techno
agroenvironnementales écoute d'abd el
fad meilleur un détail que tu dis que
c'est pas vrai jeu comme what saison
mais hop le gel corrige ses plaies ça
c'est cool fait que la bonne critique je
laime joie débattre avec le monde qui
tout j'adore ça mais mais les
commentaires violents
vraiment c'est de la grosse violence des
commentaires gratuits mais faut dire que
je suis vendu à une compagnie sucre
exergue les pharmaciens qui l'ont vendu
par les pharmaciens fait que je suis
biaisé complètement ce qui est quand
même drôle parce que moi je suis
vraiment je suis vraiment aucun patron
du jeu paf il ya aucune bannière a
aucune compagnie et ses jeux partie de
l'industrie pharmaceutique parce que je
découvrais des niaiseries qui se faisait
là dedans je pense pas en avoir de
conflit d'intérêts tac quand quelqu'un
me dit jose kamba tour le second était
vendu comme c'est sûr qui dit qu'il faut
c'est naturel de la mort devant les pe
vert l'épée le ceci plate parce que ce
genre de discussion là dessus le 5e
savoir aller nulle part mais c'est ça en
plus du site donne comme mission mettons
qu'on prend position maintenant par
rapport aux véganisme mac à peine de
mort sur beaucoup de messages mais je me
suis jamais dit je réponds à tout parce
que répond à toutes
des fois il ya un message si tu vois tu
lis le tulle et la première phrase puis
tu sais que pas fini avant demain matin
a argumenté que cette personne là on
laisse juste faire et les gens qui
veulent juste à faire du mal ces pannes
et ça m'a dit rollin parce que tu sais
on parle beaucoup des trolls
présentement les trolls stop c'est pas
un si gros problème que ça de mon point
de vue là pour avoir passé beaucoup de
temps sur le web
moi mon temps à les tranchées que les
trolls mais moi je sais que tu décris
leur est autrement dit des gens que tout
de suite le dans la façon qui t'amène
leur animal sur le sucre jamais cas pas
de voir la fin de cette discussion là tu
le vois que la personne en réalité
ah le pauvre vraiment d'intérêt de se
faire contredire ou juste dans ton point
de vue elle elle arrive là pour faire
son point qui à votre avis avant de
débattre à l'infini c'est même moi c'est
la même affaire puis même je dois même
d'information continue maintenant ou aux
professeurs la santé patiente ific là
dessus c'est sûr choisir ses combats
parce que on a tendance beaucoup à focus
sur les minorités qui sont extrêmement
comme très bruyante violentes lancées
comme justement dans les foyers déjà
qu'ils me disent ah airways et vegan
c'est en haut là dans l'action et ange
comme tous les ans tu suivais gamme gens
se sentent intense en tabarnouche sans
occulter comme une faune par ces gens
leur job souvent avec les anti vaccins
etc où ces gens là on passe bel trop de
temps se préoccuper de monde le sandjak
comme on était mieux de les laisser
faire ces thérapies de parler avec le
monde qui ont envie de parler pour de
vrai qu'une certaine ouverture
nous on en parlait autrefois je pense
qu'avec avec ton frère
puis c'était la seule à sablons je pense
qu'ils étaient vegan qui disait c'est
une quelconque sortie natif de recettes
qui attise étiez lyon ils m'appuient on
vient d'en apprendre mes autres ceux qui
quittent déjà vegan puis la réponse
était non justement parce que ce pas toi
qu'on parle de ça ça me fait penser à ce
que tu dis z qui parlent pas aux
convertis des je ne sais pas ce que je
fais non plus si je parle à ceux qui
s'intéressent à ce petit jeu c'est le
sait - france à moi mais j'essaie de
focus est sûre ce s'intéressent à ce
type je vois que se posent sur les
vegans fois qu'ils se posent sur ceux
qui s'en foutent complètement mais je
crois que ça ce qui m'écrivent une
question hamza béton
elle est achetée talbot je le savais pas
qu'est ce que je fais maintenant mais
c'est été gardés acheté depuis mai au
moins un peu la question aux peugeot se
contractant de la réponse est trop
gentil que toi tu ce genre de
conversation là c'est ce que tu préfères
si oui pis moi encore je me souviens
faut que je me rende que faut souvent je
me pose la question pourquoi je fais ce
taux d'aujourd'hui parce que honnêtement
le jeu souffre c'est 90% de souffrance
pour 10 % de blancs et en général fait
que je me repose sur mirage et
décourager des gens courageux dieu merci
le messin jokes et comme il y en a plein
d'autres qui font le qui font des
enfants dans leurs domaines respectifs
sera pas facile mais mes faux choix je
me pose la question pourquoi je fais ce
déjà puis moi ça me ramène tout le temps
moi je veux essayer d'améliorer l'aspect
critique des gens c'est fait maintenant
qu'on parle du véganisme j'ai fait un
épisode de la série télé là dessus
qu'ils m'ont épisode n'est pas prouvée
ganis n'est pas anti big and his music
tour regardons les arguments qui sont
avancés par rapport aux véganisme du
voyons qu est ce que la leur qu'est-ce
que pas d'ailleurs la dap forcément que
yoyo des arguments propos le véganisme
qui sont pas bons ayant nos comptes qui
sont pas bons aussi toi je pense que
c'est un avantage de tout le monde
ok que on arrête de dire des faux
argument par rapport à des affaires qui
est un exemple classique de sa tante au
dessus m'a parlé du lait combien de fois
des gens qui vont me dire et savait tout
sur toi que l'être humain c'est le seul
mammifère à boire le lait d'une autre
espèce
qu'est ce qu'on s'en sacre de ce que les
autres espèces y font le jeu dire comme
on s'en fout de ce que les ours polaires
fond puis on s'en fout complètement
c'est pas un bon argument ceni tacle
dans ce cas ci c'est utilisé comme un
argument qui hantent il est c'est pas un
bon argument d'alain vers ce soit à voir
des gens comme l'industrie laitière qui
va dire le lait c'est très important
pour être en bonne santé sur non plus
c'est pas un bon argument souvent moi ce
que je me rends compte si dans la
plupart des questions de santé de
sciences en général c'est que dans les
deux cas les scellés qu'un pro pro pour
contente xterra les deux lions des
arguments qui sont louches qui
mériterait d'être nuancée est ce que est
ce que tu penses que dans un sujet comme
celui là comme le véganisme par exemple
parce que tu penses que l'aspect éthique
vient donner une plus d'émotion à
certains cas dans certains argumentent
c'est l'argument que tu viens tu viens
de dire le béton et c'est pas ta mère
c'est pas ton les bâtons cet argument
est ce que ce le fait que pour des gens
qui sont qui sont touchés par l'éthique
animale par la façon que les faits dans
la façon que le veau par exemple été
enlevés de la mer est ce que ça va aller
chercher beaucoup ces six stars du manga
qui met de l'avant mais l'éthique la
science est ce que ça se croisent à
certains moments
ben oui totalement bah oui absolument et
puis d'ailleurs dans - j'ai interviewé
une chercheure en éthique animal qui
s'appelle valérie giroud qui super super
intéressante vraiment pis elles
essentiellement ce que ce cas motus que
je voulais jouer avec elle c'est qu'est
ce qu'on est capable de dire
scientifiquement mettons sur l'éthique
animale c'est comme qu'est ce qu'on sait
sur l'intelligence des animaux sur la
souffrance que dirait on n'en sait pas
mal
nous on en sait beaucoup tout à fait
recommandé quand les gens font disent
des choses du genre est une vache ses
caves mais ce come as tu envie de suivre
et c'est maintenant on est capable de
répondre jusqu'à un certain point je
suis quand même des questions est
exactement après que pilote c'est le
monde comme pour moi c'est là que ça
devient vraiment intéressant parce que
c'est principalement les trois arguments
par exemple pour le véganisme c'est
l'éthique animale l'environnement que la
santé on vous dit
chaque personne trouve un peu sa porte
d'entrée là dedans - clairement de mon
point de vue qui est pas mon le bon
point de vue mais mon point de vue je
trouve que l'argument le plus
convaincant s'est définitivement
l'éthique animale
ouais bah oui c'est
parce que je dis la viande est
optionnelle dans la vie de toute façon
fait que si les animaux souffrent
horriblement en produire de la viande
pour moi ç'a dû chance de dire on va
arrêter d'en manger à partir de là le
taux plein on peut se demander si c'est
facile à faire et que ses termes et
métiers on est capable de se dire ben
maintenant aux morts le camp tu le mets
dans l'eau bouillante c'est un sentiment
est ce que c est ce qu est ce qu est ce
qu un cochon ça a des émotions ça peut
avoir par ce sont des questions
auxquelles on peut essayer de répondre
ces anciens avec ce mouvement fait que
quand les gens font comme moi le truc
animal le souci juste comme nous qui
décide de la faire d'annoncé on est
potes là c'est plus juste dans un mot
j'aime les animaux j'aime tous les
animaux ce comme quoi le système nerveux
humain animal comment ça fonctionne
crise en sciences la fameuse s'en tient
exactement les animaux sensibles ces
thérapies tout soit fait pour moi ce
sont des arguments qui sont si petits
qu'ils sont à mon avis très fort pour
pour au minimum diminuer énormément
notre consommation de viande
c'était moi maintenant parce que j'ai vu
ta face qui te fait craquer les tic à
l'image est une phase mais juste pour
moi l'argument qui m'a le plus
l'environnement la ferme et à ses
personnels la différence puis c'est ce
que je voulais dire tout à l'heure quand
tu parlais de la santé moi je suis 100%
d'accord
admettons j'ai du monde qui me disent
moi et pour ma santé je diminue ma
commence une consommation bien c'est
parfait
la maison pour sa santé et pour
l'environnement jeu diminuer ma
consommation en viande c'est parfait
mais pour l'éthique animale diminuer sa
consommation bien c'est pas si loin si
c'est ça le problème en moins c'est ça
la différence en trois arguments je
pense c'est compliqué parce que puis je
suis d'accord avec toi dans le sens que
un manet chacun si je pense que tous les
arguments sont bons si les arguments
sont bons mais ils ont tout des nuances
à apporter dans chaque cas doit donner
des exemples qui devenir de meute ont
coupé ses 100 % des produits animaliers
pour la santé ça tient pas la route
parce que c'est pas mauvais pour la
santé est un allié avec si tu dis - le
sait je consomme plus de viande
la langue c'est mauvais ben je m'excuse
mais tout autant c'est pas vrai tu peut
consommer de la viande est en bonne
santé
c'est juste que de ses problèmes en une
bonne idée d'en consommer le moins
possible
mettez vous en consommez 0 les arguments
santé de mon point de vue c'est les
moins bons c'est ceux qui sont les moins
fort pour supporter des dyades plus
végétalienne vegan apprécié à l'argument
environnemental y est excellent du point
de vue de l'industrie c'est à dire que
l'industrie de l'élevage
si une des industries les plus
polluantes donc si on est capable de
changer de les réglementations pour que
ça change mais ça va aider mais c'est
sûr que nous on sera pas d'illusions le
men ou non nos habitudes alimentaires
personnel ont un impact qui est vraiment
très très faible sur l'environnement
quand même ça fera des mesures à très
large échelle pour avoir des vrais
impact - suis-je devient vegan toi
studien vegan totti des vegan ça va pas
changer grand chose pour l'environnement
le jeu de renesse question peut-être 100
si on fait nos sens de la demande
l'industrie g ça passe c'est exactement
puis un passage je suis comme je dis je
suis tout à fait sensible à la cause
si comme citoyens ont fait pression sur
le gouvernement pour changer des choses
éventuellement ça c'est un vrai exemple
là où il faut pas s'illusionner cette
pensée que nous nos habitudes personnel
change quelque chose s'est dit je sais
que c'est triste de réaliser ce que je
chausse bien qui conduit sa voiture
électrique et sur les billets persuadé
de faire de quoi de bien pour
l'environnement il fait pas vraiment de
quoi bien pour l'environnement lorsque
ça va prendre c'est comme des 10 ddd
déduction de taxes le massif pour que
les gens changent voir des voitures
électriques
la viande par exemple ça prend de
changer je sais pas mais le guide
alimentaire canadien de taxer la viande
moi je connais pas sur le sport mon
domaine mais ça va prendre des
changements à large à très large échelle
radical faction c'est des choses qui ont
un réel impact qui après sa belle
éthique animal bah c'est sûr que là il
ya des gens qui vont dire ben moi je
m'en fous d'un tyran que les gens disent
oh mais en a qui vont dire comme ben moi
non mais les gens du cycle de la vie qui
je m'entends ce sont exactement par
contre moi je n'ai pas de problème avec
ça si les gens disent moussa mais ne
m'interpelle beau les arguments ou
outils de beaucoup de fermiers par
exemple j'ai parlé à des fermiers qui
disent garde mes vaches les aime le kiwi
ça me fait de la peine quand à
l'abattoir mais c'est juste de même que
ça marche
je les comprends honnêtement si colleu
je les comprends pensé comme ceux de st
mais par contre c'est sûr que si tu leur
dis bah
la vache à un certain niveau de
souffrance parce qu'on est peut-être
capable de mesurer là ça devient
difficile comme contre durrrr seul je
comprends pas comment ils vont
contredire ça et ça rejoint ted pas leur
valeur
mais il ya peut-être des choses qui
pourraient quand même admettre un texte
seul problème ce qui est beaucoup de 15
ce moment qu'ils veulent pas beaucoup
changé leur position
c'est ce qui fait que tim est très mince
au fait dans le fond il faut connaître
les faits plutôt que spring navale
d'opinion sénat faire des connaissances
exactement pitié ça va prendre ça prend
des changements massifs le en ce moment
si la peau si la population est derrière
ce qui a fait changer les choses moi je
trouve ça cool je trouve ça super mais
en même temps c'est pas vrai que moi je
vais aller dire aux gens
comme je te dise que ce que tu manges le
ça fait une différence massive
c'est probablement polka mais ça devrait
pas empêcher par contre de faire ces
changements là c'est vraiment parler de
ce mail est ce que les gens qui font les
lois aussi le veut pas pas seulement
télé conscience à part de l'idée
transmed piquant que les gens qui font
du gouvernement voire vegan vont être
conscientiser ils vont être au courant
de ces faits les choses ont changé aussi
factice c'est que les gens soient plus
conscientisés en général totalement puis
garde moi mon rêve des enfants les plus
hautes que j'ai vue d'un récemment c'est
à w qui ont fait une meilleure bien mais
bon ça reste plus qu'à inventer la boule
est bon mais en passant c'est de la crap
total j'ai pas envie de manger mais ceci
étant dit quand même c'est quand même
une grosse chaîne de fast food qui dit m
maintenant on va faire une boulette
végétal ce qui va faire que ça va
peut-être allumé des petites lumières
d'une taille de certaines personnes qui
vont écrire ses rangs du coup le vous y
rendre intéressant peut-être que je
pourrai site marchand moody le cc soldat
porte c'est tout c'est de la clape ces
deux-là club ces deux femmes non mais
c'est de la cdu fast food le jeu je peux
recommander à personne d'aller manger du
fast food de manger de temps en temps
mais c'est pas de la bonne alimentation
une hausse atteint la boulette végétal
est pas meilleure pour la santé que la
boulogne en ces termes nutritionnelle
c'est pourri dans les deux cols à
quelqu'un plus de sel que dreux ils vont
ajuster un peu les saveurs puis tout ça
mais c'est de la cochonnerie les deux le
tien mais quand même tu vas voir là
dedans pipe mais par contre si jamais
manié toutes les chaînes de fast-food
isabella on va passer a su
progressivement
ben c'est eux les gros acheteurs de
viande exact où un autre exemple c'est
amener ce bruit ont annoncé que
subway ont annoncé qu'ils allaient juste
acheter de la viande qui étaient nourris
sans antibiotiques
ok toit puis moi on mange de la viande
qui était une ruse antibiotiques là ça
change absolument rien pour notre santé
ne se reconnaît pas qu'il en reste plus
d'antibiotiques dans viande dans l'est
on attend c'est aussi sûrement nui des
dentifrices associations et ça se peut
pas puis de là les hormones jouent
désormais c'est sûr que des hormones
l'ambiance et de la viande y en a dans
ton corps aussi désormais blues ont
encore en viande avec le problème ce
n'est pas de consommer de la viande des
antibiotiques mais c'est que ce bruit là
c'est comme un des plus gros acheteurs
de viande craxi lui et décide de changer
ça le reste de l'industrie le bnia pas
le choix qui sera choisie pour donner
moins d'antibiotiques et le ça a un
impact sur pleine affaire comme la
résistance aux antibiotiques fait et
c'est fait avec des fois c'est là où ça
devient intéressant quand un gros
joueurs amenés à cause de la pression
populaire dit bonjour changer la pile
est faible parce que sa population
double vie mais c'est parce que c'est
que ça bavarde qui exactement
alors que concrètement moins le cas du
monde mange des boulettes de burgers
good végétale ou pour le meilleur mais
ça c'est certain qu'il faut pas se
leurrer non plus tu sais c'est que ces
commandes est en taule je peux pas
quitter vegan ta santé c'est pas une
cause à effet le direct non absolument
absolument pas absolument pas mais
métier c'est ça c'est que si ça peut
faire prendre conscience de certaines
aux jeunes certaines choses comme par
exemple le celtic oms et diminue la
consommation même site une bonne façon
de les améliorer son alimentation en
général partie si la personne a voici ce
qu'a fait comme crime si big
présentement le mouvement du bijou tout
peut-être que je devrais essayer
d'embarquer un peu là dedans à ma façon
ben pourquoi pauline pour ces compagnies
comme présent mais y'a des gens qui sont
contre il ya des gens qui sont contre
toutes sortes d'affaires comme justement
là là là les poules est justement
végétale ou toute souffrance
oui comme il ya une compagnie aux états
unis qui s'appelle burger le mangez
bougez pas goûté mais apparemment que
c'est ce que plus proche en ce moment de
la boulette de
il ya plein de groupes environnementaux
en ce moment qui sont contre cette
boulette là en sortant toutes sortes
d'arguments dix ans on devrait pas
essayer d'imiter de la viande des ogm là
dedans des enfants je comprends pomme
cette affaire laisse comme n'importe
quoi en ce moment que technologiquement
on peut inventer pour améliorer les
choses
on devrait se réjouir on aurait tout
être content je ne cache pot en ce
moment où même les gens qui sont contre
la viande in vitro qui disent oui j'en
fais de la viande in vitro c'est pas bon
mais collins parce que si on n'a pas
besoin son petit animal puis de ruminer
l'environnement pour pourquoi pourquoi
se pose reste c'est un job que je n'ai
catch pas cette affaire lot d'exception
c'est que c'est changer les mentalités
c'est ce qui est le plus difficile je
n'ai je pas rentrer je faisais un livre
l'autre jour à nico express à une fille
qui fait sa maîtrise
l'environnement finalement c'est ça la
schl a subi on attend souvent la chose
que la chose la plus significative qu'on
peut faire pour l'environnement c'est
d'être vegan mais est là disait à 10
aces et dans les meilleurs m'a dit c'est
pas numéro 1 c'est trop 4 à 10 016 pas
d'enfants mais des numéros de placer son
argent dans des fonds verts
c'est quelque chose qu'on n'a pas
beaucoup parlé mais apparemment c'est
moche ça changerait tout
c'est tout le monde faisait ça si tout
le monde faisait n'importe quoi depuis
le positif ça serait fantastique grave
est métaphorique l impact que ça
omettant est plus grand mais au tour
c'était prendre l'avion ne pas prendre
puis s'est sauvé bien d'autres après
exactement ça c'est encore là tu sais si
c'est tout le taux de chute par les
sentir et ce maillot le pacte les bacs
pour la transition que plein de gens
aussi nié puis ça fait aussi du gros
backlash du monde n'était pas content
d'être 2e et s'était rapidement j'ai
beaucoup réfléchi la duchère pas trop me
positionner petit ultima je me suis dit
qu'à un paquet de monde qui signent une
pétition en disant je vais essayer de
réfléchir à mon impact environnemental
difficilement comment ça pourrait être
quelque chose de négatif
juste des artistes qui sont un peu dans
des contradictions plutôt ton chance
actu dessus dans le fonds tient mais ça
reste quand même justement ça amène des
questions qui peuvent être très
confrontant oui mais justement comme si
quoi que le plus gros impact sur les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
rabbins c'est d'avoir posé pas avoir un
kit de matos comme aux chiffres ne songe
pas prêt à faire ce que tu es prêt à
faire le guet qu'est-ce qui est le plus
simples au quotidien pour changer avec
le plus grand impact et le rapport un
pack nécessité leur avis les tripes
la réponse est souvent souvent véganisme
c'est pour ça que c'est la chose la plus
en gros sacrifices voyage et puis encore
l'os c'est moi ça me ramène tout le
temps qui je sais que c'est paul fans de
dire ça mais quel impact ont encore sur
la patente global probablement pas si tu
as une personne qui conduit une voiture
électrique c'est une personne qui décide
pas avoir d'enfant pour l'environnement
c'est une personne décide de devenir
vegan des initiatives individuelles
c'est bien cool puis on fait des choses
en fonction de nos valeurs puis moi
aussi mais la réalité c'est que ça ne
m'a pas vraiment tant d'impact c'est ce
que ça prend le sait des mesures
drastiques
pis il faut que ça vienne de top c'est
ce que viennent de tom et la honte le
problème c'est la réélection
parce que aussi fait les avec des
mesures drastiques propos et les autres
et il faut le problème c'est que les
gouvernements
il faut que charme il faut que charme pi
6 po avec la france et les enjeux
scientifiques lé pour les élections
c'est la pire c'est les gouvernements ne
sont pas des experts en sciences etc
tous les enjeux scientifiques qui sont
toutes un peu vu comme glisse un des
clubs aux dernières élections du québec
solidaire qui a utilisé le
l'environnement le bateau comme étant
leur la faire pour pour fonctionner du
moins j'ose espérer qu'ils vont rester
dans cette lignée là le les autres
partis ça va les amener y ont reproché
de compétitionner avec les y vont comme
ramener plus des arguments
environnementaux fait dans ce sens là
c'est probablement une bonne affaire
mais en même temps la dernière personne
sur qui je me fit rien pour me parler
d'environnement c'est le gouvernement au
même titre que la dernière personne sur
qui je me ferais pour me parler de vega
nice et des documentaires vegan sur
netflix josse et ce ne sont pas des gens
qu'on devrait écouter c'est pour les
groupes
les groupes environnementaux dont moi je
les écoute sur rien ne veut rien savoir
des autres je veux pas entendre ce
qu'ils ont à dire sur rien moi je vais
en entendre parler
les scientifiques qui sont spécialisés
sur la question si tu veux parler de gaz
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre
ahmed moins scientifique qui est
spécialisé là dedans tout les lobbys le
qu'ils soient gouvernementaux qu'ils
soient idéologique une n'importe quoi le
jeu désolé le mispo eux que je veux
entendre qu'on parle de science
demandons l'avis des scientifiques
cloutier est ce que est ce qu'au fédéral
et chef qu'avec harper toutes les études
qui avaient rapport à l'environnement
devra être approuvée pour être diffusés
par le
approuvé par le gouvernement pour être
sorti ce que c'est gros comme ça avec
tout ce que je sais pas honnêtement quel
point ça a changé de ces je sais qu'avec
harper s'est apparemment que c'était
vraiment pas terrible le théorique mais
ça peut exister à plusieurs niveaux
ainsi c'est à dire que ça on aime ce
imaginer que la science est comme
complètement indépendante de tout est
exagéré c'est pas vrai c'est parce qu'il
ya tout le temps des facteurs qui
influencent x y z puis même un chercheur
par exemple ça veut étudier telle
affaire mais si on n'obtient pas de
financement pour faire cette recherche
le bail propos la face à recherche
mais là il ya un autre sujet qui est
bien au tpi ça il va obtenir du
financement là dessus et qui va faire
des recherches sur quelque chose qui
veut que pas vraiment envie de faire de
la recherche là dessus après ça il ya
certains titres de financement ou la
personne qui finance ou le groupe qui
finance peut avoir certains droit de
regard sur la recherche qui peut faire
que ils peuvent dés fois influencé
qu'est ce qui va ce publié ou pout cfec
sait jamais c'est la science est jamais
complètement non influencé les sources
extérieures beaucoup les scientifiques
ils sont peu plus souvent de leur tour
d'ivoire comme ça qu'on les entend pas
assez pour regarder leur objectivité ou
pour se mêler à la politique parce que
c'est des gars comme toi on naviguait
vulgarisation scientifique au québec mtq
s'il y en a pas tant que ce qui je pense
que plusieurs raisons à cela une des
raisons le mentionner tantôt c'est qu'il
faut que tu fous que soient créées avant
de la souffrance le train qui vous
sauvera avoir des menaces de mort et de
faire envoyer des photos de toi qui sort
de chez vous des enfants de membres
or je ne dis pas tout le monde qui a
envie de vivre ça le comprend après ça
il ya aussi le fait que souvent les gens
qui sont dans des domaines des sciences
très très pointu c'est souvent des geeks
extrêmes sur leur domaine
c'est des purs passionnés c'est des gens
qui vont tout donner pour leurs
recherches qui vont des fois avoir des
vies de misère pour mener leurs
recherches à terre niveau des fois pas
voir de financer des chercheurs des fois
ils vont perdre toute leur équipe de
recherche puis vont continuer eux-mêmes
à faire les manipulations dans leurs
larmes c'est dit c'est dit passionné
fait qu'ils n'ont pas le goût ils n'ont
pas le temps de nécessairement
s'investir sur des plateformes plus
public fait que ça n'en prend plus
mais c'est pas très vendeur sandjak de
faire de la communication scientifique
là c'est pas la sphère la plus sexy
mettons notre jeu la prescience que
moussant sont intéressants mouvement
plus est ce que dans les dernières
années j'ai l'impression que hugh une
curiosité scientifique qui s'éveille ses
habitudes je pense qu'il ya un intérêt
pour certaines affaires où il y avait
peut-être pas d'intérêt avant la santé
c'est un bon jeu très bon exemple c'est
à dire que maintenant les gens ça c'est
ça les intéresse la santé s'est rendue
même cool si je vous dis un des blogs de
santé avec des ago et avec grand intérêt
et cela c'est la fois la plus tough la
fin mais plutôt à venir c'est l'intérêt
fait mouche pour ce fantastique moi lol
si c'est moi j'ai gradué en 2004 la
somme avait été en 2004
comment mener le la santé ça serait
income sujet j'aurais jamais cru ça est
long le maintenant fuck you regain
d'intérêt donc à ce moment là c'est bon
on peut capitaliser là dessus c'est
l'homme maintenant c'est sûr que ce qui
vient avec ça c'est un paquet de
bullshit et le évidemment le faut comme
on ne les intérêts du mono leur
attention
une photo leur attention le faut que tu
commences à faire le ménage dans leur
croyance est belle c'est vrai c'est pas
vrai fait que fixer comme ça dans
beaucoup d'autres domaines des sciences
en ce moment les gens sont intéressés
mais soyons jamais été aussi dépourvu
dans un sens de communistes ils savent
encore moins que qu'à 20 comment s'y
retrouver à travers toute cette masse
d'informations seul gros défi en ce
moment
[Musique]
ces malaises une question j'ai une
question par exemple
dernier sujet qui way
bougez pleinement l'otan des mois qu'ils
font qui jouit pitt a fait un épisode là
dessus avec les aventures de faire
machine puis moi je m'attardais que moi
je pensais que les démolir le jeune
terme tant pis le jeune yannick ces
intermittents pianenc séjourné pendant
3-4 jaune de trop quel jeu droit et
différentes méthodes
puis finalement la conclusion de
l'émission c'est qu'ils peuvent
tellement conclusion cpo vraiment encore
c'est bon pas bon exemple on le sait pas
trop qui
je me laisse ainsi la science ou si
l'idée le seul à évoluer ou si c'est
encore une question - aucun sujet que je
démolis complètement sauf quand c'est
des absurdités totales
un bug des cures détox puis de
l'homéopathie 6 pi et du monde qui
disent que de consommer des ogm c'est
toxique le sou je vois les joueurs
liégeois démolir ces arguments la pasta
tient pas la route
mais quand on arrive dans des trucs
comme le jeune homme elle l'a dit c'est
aux gens qui les gens qui ont écouté mon
épisode sur l'a10 de cet agenda enfin je
dis pas c'est de la cochonnerie l'a dit
cet agent je vois pas pourquoi on dirait
si c'est juste que c'est quoi l'état de
la science sur la question qu'est ce
qu'on sait sur le jeune ben on a des
études in vitro qui démontrent certaines
affaires on a des études chez les
animaux qui demandent certaines affaires
c'est intéressant voulons continuer à
faire de la recherche là dessus chez
l'humain qu'est-ce qu'on a pas grand
chose on au ban des témoignages des
anecdotes puis d afrique on est en fait
qu'ils sont bel fans m'ont n'a pas grand
chose de concret à partir de là est-ce
que c'est dangereux
je n'ai probablement points dans la pop
art déco à moins d'aller d'un tueur de
jeunes qu'ils ont 20 jours pour le
conseil les mêmes du trot jour le cpo
dangereux
encore là ça dépend c'était une personne
en bonne voie je conseillerais pas
personne pas même un bémol je conserve
ma personne de jeu une impasse que c'est
pas quelque chose de si utile jusqu'à
preuve du contraire
puis je conseillerais pas déjà de jeunes
et sans supervision même en fait les top
expert dans le monde qui font de la
recherche là dessus 10 la même affaire
qui ne recommande même pas aux gens de
jeunes et sans supervision médicale qui
est quelqu'un que des problèmes de santé
il pourrait commander devrait avoir des
gros problèmes reliés à ceux ci fait que
mais c'est ça le jeune intermittents par
exemple c'est pas très intense c'est le
jeûne intermittent ça peut être par
exemple de dire beaucoup de monde qu'est
ce qu'ils font c'est qu'ils vont ils
vont sous peu ils vont s'équiper le
déjeuner puis ensuite ils vont juste 19
ans qui vont en voir un jeune de quoi 12
des x 14 heures des choses comme ça
c'est pas dangereux
la théorie quand encore répond en mode
digestion est en mode réparation pour
voir ben et moi c'est ça la fait rire
c'est comme si vous avez des théories la
belle théorie mais avant n'importe quoi
passer mois déjà que jeune j'en ai
rencontré apache et il était depuis à
peu près deux ans il te monde le fait
pour des raisons différentes y en a qu
il il y en a pas tant qu'ils font pour
perdre du poids et bizarrement selon les
études qu'on a les petites études ça
s'en remettent pour ce que c'est plus
efficace
c'est un risque lié à une forme de tours
de la fin le client n'est que 10e c'est
pour régénérer les cellules votre
coiffure regénérer où était le corps est
réparé et encore il y ait eu de la
misère à se préparer en ce moment j'ai
toujours pensé que c'est les nutriments
justement qui avec qui venait mettons au
team et ton petit entraîne le pis le
dimanche et les protéines et aide à
réparer des musiques et voix pour les
micros philly micro déchirure des
muscles des choses comme ce roi et si
cette année encore l'homme s'ils veulent
dire que le jeune ait pour la
performance sportive
moi j'ai pas de problème avec ça mais
fait l'étude démontré le à vendre
n'importe quoi
et puis ils ont la possibilité de les
faire ces financements pour le jeune
parce que ses hôtes en ce moment c'est
un sujet de recherche qui est hot fait
que ça fait qu'ils font pourquoi ils
font pour booster leur métabolisme
ça veut dire quoi ça veut rien dire je
t'aime à aider le corps à se réparer
lui-même saisir quoi ça veut rien dire
la majorité des raisons pas les genres
ou pour se détoxifier ça c'est la raison
principale les gens jeunes parce que 10
c'est pour donner un break amont cordes
l'aide à éliminer plus facilement les
toxines que les déchets ça veut rien
dire
thaksin je sais pas c'est quoi les
personnages et roger j'ai aucune idée
qu'est ce que c'est thaksin exactement
je connais beaucoup de déchet cellulaire
mais des toxines je sais pas c'est quoi
avec ce soit il impressionne beaucoup de
gens jeunes pour les mauvaises raisons
que beaucoup de gens aussi qui gêne pour
se mettre dans un état de cette hausse
qui est un état où tu brûles finalement
tu tombes sur tes sources secondaires de
carburant dans un sens le ticket
beaucoup le gros c'est le même principe
dans la disette c'est aux gens les gens
disent moi je vais t'en cette hausse
parce qu'en cet âge là tu deviens plus
intelligent le cerveau fonctionne mieux
ça fait 6 à fait sûr bla bla bla
amèrement un bonne chance pour être
cette eau en faisant le jeu verra moins
de jeûner pendant deux trois semaines tu
seras pas cette hausse avec encore
l'oeil à plein de monde qui se promènent
mais j'en ai rencontré dans rue du monde
y ait moins de puissance est au jeu
tellement mieux comment vis tu fais quoi
aux jeunes et ermitage skip le déjeuner
tout ce qui donne en match et quand même
ok double y penser tous avec les
bienfaits que les bienfaits qui en ce
moment je sais pas c'est quoi elle si
tout est vrai bien fist eu d'effet
placebo fait le jeune est ce que ça
avance et non sap a avancé on est au
même stade et moins
le jour où on va avoir des études qui
vont nous dire que ça marche pour telle
affaire et que steffi kas où quelque
chose doit être heureux de le
recommander
et ma prédiction là dessus c'est que si
c'est utile pour quelque chose ça va
être utile pour une micro portion la
société genre une personne qui a eu
qu'un quadruples pontage que le syndrome
métabolique qui est un comme tout les
toutes les indicateurs de santé son
commentaire lundi tout écart de marc
dans le jeu
j'ai un enfant de même l'appui que le
web cette personne-là avoir tiré un
petit bien fait aux jeunes intermittente
c'est souvent seul et les diètes un peu
frêle je l'utilisais un peu faux cul
peuple souvent tu te rends compte
en bout de ligne ok c'est efficace mais
c'est efficace pour une niche de la
population et c'est souvent sur la
réalité parce que la majorité des gens
s'ils ont une alimentation variée et
équilibrée
si ils vont être probablement correct
mais olivier beaucoup d'avoir la liste
est cool c'est une conversation ultra
jazz en couches sont des gens qui ont
coûté appris beaucoup il ya ma maison
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté pour
cette belle conversation et celle tout
le monde a eu